I am up renard we are here live as
always in Hollywood on Hollywood
Boulevard at these scum and villainy
cantina put your hands together to the
folks at home know your real this is the
place where you could kill a
[ __ ] flip a quarter and be like
sorry for the mess
how are you good sir I am great man I'm
I've been looking forward to being back
in the villa nice gun place yes yeah me
too this is one of my favorite things to
do in the world and [ __ ] but you've got
I'll just cut to the chase you got a
special guest tonight I do I have a
special guest for whom I'm going to
attempt to do a clean show oh my god now
yeah I can't I can't work blue tonight
otherwise I will not hear the end of it
I don't know yeah because my mom is in
the house she's waving like a lunatic
right oh yeah take your bow mom take
your bow that is very very cool and we
were we were out you know the green room
of this place is neither green nor a
room it's the back alley and so we were
standing out back and I was like you
must be so proud of your son he's come
all the way from New Jersey and he
brought you to a back alley in Los
Angeles how sweet man how long is mom in
town for about a week and a half but are
we gonna have the kids or in their
school breaks so this was an opportune
time and also New York is buried in snow
and waffle button out here at 76 and
sunny so now what role does mom play and
you've been a you know nerd and a geek
and a guy who likes this kind of stuff
she was wonderfully indulgent when I was
a kid because she could care less about
any of this stuff it was always we is it
a star war or
fine we'll go see it alright these these
little kittens are cute that Ewoks mom I
know whatever he walks for kittens hey
you know it's furry it kind of had ears
and Yub Yub whatever she was very
indulgence like your mom was like I was
dealing with a real life [ __ ] I totally
know we're gonna come to a Star Wars bar
it was like oh like in the Star Wars
movie I'm like yeah she's like really I
didn't have to do enough of this you
were 9 well apparently not at least
you're consistent from 9:00 till now oh
yeah you're gonna stay the course at
some point it'll break for me yeah he'll
grow up I'm sure one day it's coming
yeah no time soon you don't get to make
your journey which has been incredible
unless she makes her journey man so give
it up for marks mom Freddie yeah she did
not Blanche when it's I gotta go and buy
some D&D dice did you have enough dice
we have backgammon in the house what I
need more dice I needed dodecahedron mom
is that 20 sides why do you mean 20
sides were the dice all right let's go I
had one of those god bless you just not
with dandy I would have never bothered
my mother with that she might elect
called the police for the D&D show no
I'm a dungeon master she's like don
phoned the police great so that's
awesome your mom is in the house and
stuff and we will try to watch our
language in a big bad way well you don't
have to your mom's not here [ __ ] I
[Laughter]
have to go home for the next nine days
but did you hear that boy it's true
there's a certain amount of cursing I
have to do per week it's expected it's
in my contract
okay what else has been going on I went
to Disneyland yesterday this is gonna
sound this is gonna sound gross and I
don't want this to sound gross but I
honestly feel it is good advice for
anybody going to Disneyland with
children yeah
so you can go Disneyland any number of
ways and stuff but they won't let you in
unless you pay of course and it's you
know it's not it's not inexpensive no I
get you but it's worth it you get inside
and it's like all the memories of
childhood come flooding back and I went
on every ride yesterday the exception of
for rides in the span of 7 hours we were
able to do everything they still hold up
everything's still legit still like
totally works Haunted Mansion is still
like a Marvel it broke down at one point
because it's [ __ ] old maybe but it we
were frozen in the best place that
dining hall where there's a bunch of
[ __ ] going on so you we got I got to
study we were literally there for five
minutes and I got to study everything
try to figure you know I'm a whole life
I'm like how do they do it and [ __ ] it's
a mirror had enough time to be like oh I
see it but it's just [ __ ] fantastic
and you know this this is the year 2018
where we've seen you know like
incredible marvels and and technology
has turned us in from from a society of
people to people who are cyborgs they
got [ __ ] robot built into their hand
that they lived their life by and stuff
but this was such a [ __ ] amazing
throwback like to appear at weight I hit
a pothole what the [ __ ] was I just
describing haunted mansion [ __ ]
haunted mansion a throwback to a time
when like when they opened it let's say
it was 1966 or 67 or something like that
this must have been everything like if
you were a kid you had no access there
was no internet to have access to or
anything like that and you'd never seen
a guardian of the galaxy or anything
like that it would be [ __ ]
fascinating it's dumb 47 I know of 48 I
know how it all works
and now especially because I saw the
mirror and I'm still dazzled by it I'm
still like wow this is pretty [ __ ]
intense and wonderful and stuff so got
to spend the whole day and do it did
every right except for [ __ ] for
this is my advice if you have small
children they have a section on the
website you can go to and this is gonna
sound gross but you could pay for a VIP
anybody could be the VIP you just have
to have [ __ ] money and you pay the
park like a certain amount of loot per
hour and you get a minimum set hours and
then you get somebody in a name tag and
a Disney jacket and you can do anything
shy of kill children in the park like
it's incredible that dude was like the
front of my pass to everything so like
you know you take you through the exit
of every ride they put you like on a car
and you're off and running man it's the
get in Disney history the whole time and
stuff like that history was good enough
and [ __ ] but when it came to [ __ ] like
we got to Space Mountain and it was like
a 19 day wait and stuff and he was like
oh not for us you know we [ __ ] went
we want not only did we go to space but
as we got into our car the guy was gone
you want to go twice I said [ __ ] yeah
man nobody's ever asked me that I've
been married [ __ ] nearly 20 years my
wife never asked you want to go twice
like so it's like [ __ ] yeah I want to go
twice so we finished and then instantly
pulled in and then they were like wooo
and we went again man I was like
Disneyland
it was so [ __ ] wonderful and stuff so
yeah you know we were two adults and
adult child and you know we have time
and any experience with Disneyland so if
you know you go if you go you know
you're gonna weight in some [ __ ]
lines and stuff but that being said like
it was a breeze like for the three of us
and [ __ ] like that but I can't imagine
you're allowed to bring up to ten people
in your party you gotta buy park tickets
of course and this is a fee on top of it
but if you had little kids and [ __ ] like
standing in those lines a killer Jason
Mewes just took his kid to Disneyland
for the first time she's a massive
[ __ ] Disney fan and stuff and they
hit four rides over the course of the
whole day because you know those lines
will [ __ ] kill a kid and then they're
hungry and [ __ ] and everything breaks
down so if you went with like one of
these tour guides and [ __ ] you get right
into fantasy Lane
bambam bam-bam-bam sometimes twice in a
row and suddenly you've done it if the
kid like I'm tired it's like [ __ ] it
we're done and then you're out of there
it's pretty it was pretty fun and
granted I'm you know it's not like you
need to put a set aside some loot to do
it but my rationale to my wife is like
don't do this this is expensive and I
was like how often do we [ __ ] go to
Disneyland like never so this is a
one-time expense it's not like I'm gonna
be like we're doing this [ __ ] every week
and stiff that would be cost-prohibitive
but for this one time and granted there
was only three of us we could add seven
more and would have but you know
ameliorated the cost a little bit more
but it's the way to go just look it up
on the website you would never have to
wait in a Disneyland line again and [ __ ]
and people I thought people would mean
mug us and [ __ ] as we got like into a
carcass Jason always tells me story one
time he went to what's the it's his
Magic Mountain is that the thing that's
out here he went to Magic Mountain with
Ben and Matt at the height of Ben and
Matt like when they were [ __ ] oh my
god these [ __ ] are gonna cure
cancer they didn't so he was there like
when they went to the park and they got
like [ __ ] the royal treatment and
stuff without paying or anything cuz
there was just super famous and so and
so Jay said they'd like brought them in
front of everybody on lines and he was
just like all day long people were like
[ __ ] you Affleck so I was like I'm never
asking for free [ __ ] man like at the end
of the day so I was waiting for somebody
to be like [ __ ] you saw Bob was gonna be
like I paid a lot of money for this yeah
and you can do here's the website so
it's a helpful tip for anybody I know
people out there like I'm playing I
bring my kids for the first [ __ ] time
I can't imagine if you have three
[ __ ] kids in tow
I had one 19 year old nearly 19 she's 18
should be 19 in a couple months so claps
yeah totally well sitting there going
what comes first my wife's birthday and
I confused it with bless you my
daughter's birthday and my boy and our
anniversary is coming up at the end of
this month too there's a it's a holiday
corridor in our house and [ __ ] I'm not
till August nobody gives a [ __ ] about me
but right here this is the space where
it's like you got to remember this the
anyway that's my little inside [ __ ]
tips on inside anybody could [ __ ] it
thank you figure it out if you go to the
like Disneyland website but I was blown
away by the ease and convenience and
granted it's not a [ __ ] charity
you're paying for it but if you were to
be going to Disneyland with multiple
kids get a posse together and stuff it's
it's [ __ ] so clean so incredibly
clean and it is you would cost you yes
will you be a member of the press what
they do that yeah like they do that for
you they did it for me the first time I
when I was out here working for The
Hollywood Reporter and Disney called me
said hey so we redid the world of color
we would love you to come and write
about it right and I said yes I don't
care about the world of color at all but
did they said would you like to come to
the park and see everything like oh yeah
I do
and mom was making her first trip out
here was like the first summer that we
were here and so my son was now I was 13
so he would have been 8 my daughter was
nine and a half and their first time at
Disney was your first that time of
Disney well words I've got a studio host
would you like to do the cars ride again
absolutely we would would you like me to
hold your seat while you get food yes we
would would you like me to hold your
dick for you sir yes I will I am with
your kids going why dad why right so
we're 22 minutes in yeah and I already
what's it gonna last I tried so long the
mouth on this reprobate who raised this
kid every time my kid goes to music
barkis like is it gonna be like Disney
like no it's not gonna be like Disney
that's the only problem now if somebody
was like hey want to go to Disneyland
I'd be like well it depends yeah like I
don't know if I can stand in a line ever
again for anything yeah but it was
lovely and you're right like that that
sense of like what are you how do you
get to the front of this line again I'm
special man I don't know about you why
are you not at the front of line Bitsey
bless you not me I'm content to be like
I paid for it through the [ __ ] nose
but like it's Disney they'll get me in
the end anyway so
that's handing in over my money that was
this week what else does I do I'm up to
I lost 22 pounds so far since my heart
attack and I'm in a place with food
that's like completely different like
now I'm not even bitter about it like a
[ __ ] missed food and [ __ ] like that
my wife ate a pizza this week right she
was like I feel cruel but I really want
a pizza I was like oh my god I'm trying
to accomplish something here so don't
worry about locked and loaded and stuff
and pizza's not the thing that's gonna
knock me off so go crazy and she [ __ ]
did it the [ __ ] oh and it was it
smelled amazing at garlic all over and
[ __ ] like that no and the suddenly it's
weird the things you miss when you're
not really eating like suddenly I was
like I just want to taste the flower at
the bottom like you know how pizzas got
like that loose flour dust and [ __ ] I
was like just let me lick the bottom of
that pizza but still held steadfast ABS
I'm gonna grease behind her ears yeah
she's like come and get it pizza slice
bikini no no [ __ ] it was honestly like
I'm in a place with food where I'm not
like oh my god I've missed it I'm okay
to be away from it for a while and stuff
doesn't bother me yeah knock wood until
one day when it does and stuff so but
yeah so far so good program [ __ ]
working out and stuff today I was down
like three-quarters of the pound and I
was like [ __ ] because I like the day
before I dropped two pounds and stuff
like this so it's you know it's like
there's some plateauing it places and
then dropping in others and stuff so
it's been an interesting process but I'm
nearly at the halfway point the doctor
is like Lu lose 50 pounds that lose
three more pounds like I'm [ __ ]
halfway there and maybe that's where
I'll [ __ ] stay
[Music]
did it [ __ ] the doctors advice I know
what I'm doing but yeah so I'm keep
going and it's weird people keep asking
me like I keep getting emails and and
like invites and stuff from vegan
organizations because they're like hey
we're here you know like me no more
and I'm like why does this keep
happening but I found out my kid keeps
putting me forward the pyramid scheme of
vegan places like he wants to shame me
into staying vegan like she's just like
everybody knows you're vegan now so if
you eat meat it's gonna be a big
disappointment for a lot of people you
know do it for the people the community
needs you totally I'm like oh my god
alright [ __ ] burgermeister
meisterburger bother me so far I haven't
really thought about it where I'm like
oh [ __ ] out we need a [ __ ] if I saw
cow I'd bite his dick off like nothing I
really now have this different issue I
now have this distance from it where I'm
like oh I don't like turkey as much as I
like salt that I put on the turkey which
I put on a [ __ ] ton or gravy like if
I have gravy it's like I'm eating 90%
gravy 10% [ __ ] turkey so now I'm like
well I wasn't really a big fan anyway so
it's not gonna be that hard to lose as
long as they don't take away peanut
butter and jelly they can take the
[ __ ] rest man I could live off that
that's [ __ ] vegan do you know that now
I do and nobody's asked about that's my
hope as the that's the future eyes in my
future somewhere two three months down
the road there's a [ __ ] fat ass
peanut butter and jelly sandwich that's
just gonna be like come back baby
all right I think that's all guy you got
any upfront stuff I saw some movies so
what I saw a Pacific Rim uprising which
I'm sorry sounds like a porno to me
every part of that just sounds [ __ ]
filthy but how was it I liked the first
one and I know it got a lot of points
everybody's like it's new IP they
created a new IP in a new world
this is continuation yeah it's uh it's
Daffy and stupid and a whole lot of fun
it is exactly what I wanted it to be
which was giant robots punching each
other in the face yes and if that
doesn't make you happy then I don't want
to know you that's just the name of that
song it is a it is the [ __ ] the the
ingredients of happiness it launched
number one this week yes it did it was
the first thing to death rone black
panther by how much I'm like four
million dollars but made like 27 black
man was 23 Black Panthers still making
all the money though all of every dime
just rose to number five on the domestic
all-time list which is ridiculous that's
fine huge number one superhero movie of
all time because in America it be the
Avengers but oh my god man can you
imagine like number five on the all-time
list does that bode huge for Avengers or
No
war does it like people go like god I
just watched a superhero movie there's
no [ __ ] way it's like I'm almost like
getting a black panther sequel hidden
inside an Avengers movie yeah I mean I
think that's that's where it helps
because Avengers is always going to make
all the money like it was always going
to open huge and stay huge and
internationally just dominate but
there's a segment of the black panther
audience that traditionally doesn't go
see these movies like my mom who was
like sure right it's a phenomenon it's a
movement I have to take part of this I
have to see what this is all about
she's not gonna technically go see
infinity war but now she might because
like a third of its in Wakanda and hey
there's the doorman lodging again and
hey here's the things that I loved
before so that's how they get you the
first taste is free
he's one a little boy come back I'm
feeding yeah that's smart it truly is it
might be this situation is remember
after Avengers Iron Man 3 took a huge
jump now Iron Man 3 is a wonderful movie
don't get me wrong but it seemed to
benefit substantially from from the
Avenger you know he was able to do
Avengers 1.5 kinda and that's what it
feels like
oddly enough that Avengers feels like
Black Panther 1.5 based on how
successful Black Panther was and
continues to be Jesus yeah but but yeah
uprising was totally fun how is John
boyega he's good
I was upset to find out this
[ __ ] lost in space man he's
like either in Star Wars or in Pacific
Rim yeah hey they don't let him be in
movies where he's like I'm just a dude
who's got a job in a law firm so it's
fighting a larger than life I saw him on
when I was in Disney I want him to start
towards right because I was like who did
they update it for last Jedi they did
woo there's a [ __ ] scene where you go
to crate like you know with the [ __ ]
snow walkers and the gorilla walkers and
stuff like that and he's one of the guys
in it he pops up and he's like what are
you doing here Star Tours I was like oh
my god they roped the real talent into
this cuz I went on the submarine ride
which is like finding Nemo and when they
hit Marlin and Dory it's not it's like
Albert Brooks his younger brother yes
and Ellen's Nancy DeGeneres yes so it's
just slightly off brand and you can kind
of hear it in their voices and stuff so
I appreciate the fact that they got the
real people like because it took what 10
minutes be like can you stand here and
pretend you're on talking to the Star
Tours go god bless you I think that
Harry Potter riding Universal up the
game that way just going they got all
the kids back they get Ron and Hermione
and Harry and I grid they're all they
all show up to be in this like fancy
baloney and they got him just before
they all turned 40
right before they were done with the
Harry Potter yours okay what else is
this I saw I love dogs oh how is it
pooch movie I saw screening like that's
some screening somewhere where people
were allowed to bring their dogs which I
thought was adorable
it's adorable I would not go to that
because I would die slowly are you
allergic I'm allergic
oh this is great why is my chest so
tight I just did this again well dogs
can sniff out health problems so maybe
that I'll be like yeah just one he's
going down lap dance it's cute
it's super good as a boy does dog movie
and it's it's it's made with a lot of
love and a lot of care and it's super
precise and impeccable and artisanal the
way that Wes Anderson is know what a
great explanation of the film's he does
it's like marmalade
it's like organic marmalade every one of
those movies sure what's Anderson's
somewhere like I thought uh-oh is worth
a lot more than marmalade but but it's a
go pretty good accurate not to say like
I don't know like people like marmalade
instead maybe it is artisanal it's
absolutely silly it is it is under fire
somewhat for cultural appropriation in
the dog community from the dog community
are absolutely furious about this nobody
asked us but where is this Isle of Dogs
we want to be there we love dogs do is
it in is it like titular it is there is
a Island Isle of Dogs yes a bunch of
different breeds yeah like was there -
chicken no my [ __ ] money really how
do you leave a wiener dog off man I
don't know man it's a trash island and I
guess wiener dogs are better than that
it's artisanal its artisanal but so it's
good it's good there was some criticism
you know from especially significantly
Asian American culture writers and
critics who are calling to test the fact
that this is a movie that is set in
Japan but none of the characters none of
the main characters are Japanese they're
all dogs but they're all voiced by the
Wes Anderson army of players so it's you
Bill Murray's and you're Bryan
Cranston's and you're Edward Norton's
and they're all white actors playing
these dogs and that's who you empathize
with in the movie you're here for the
dogs it's said in Japan there are
Japanese humans but every time they
speak it's either translated or it's
subtitled or it's in some cases not
translated at all so the distance
between you and those characters is
significant because it's the language
barrier and so the the empathy of this
movie is not with the Japanese people
it's with the dogs and then it becomes
then why said it in Japan that's my butt
was gonna be my question like was it
necessary to set it in Japan kind of not
really like this could have been Iowa if
all we're gonna do is listen to dogs
really yeah like there's nothing
specific a very twee decision it seems
very letters decision yes like I want to
paint like cultural wallpaper behind my
drama but my drama is not about people
of this culture or characters of this
culture which is a fair criticism it is
a fun movie and I'm glad I saw it I took
my kid he kind of dug it it's weird but
he swung with the weird but I see you
kid wasn't like this is [ __ ] cultural
my cry foul that's well I would imagine
if you saw it in Japan and be voiced by
local famous stories yeah goes to the
Wes Anderson players instead but but why
why are folks mad I think it's here
they're mad because it's here they're
mad because you know the the where the
film places its emphasis where it places
its focus is not indicative of the
culture where the film is set right and
so why are we here if it's not going to
be about these people then it becomes
just again just tinsel on a tree that
doesn't belong did it at any point while
you're watching the movie did that
bother you once or twice really would
you talk too soon as well yeah I mean it
doesn't happen that often like I'm not
gonna say that you have to be looking
forward to see it because you know all
the human characters are japanese except
for one white girl who's like Greta
Gerwig didn't like what is she doing
here and why is it Greta Gerwig and why
is she the only one I understand like
dude none of these Japanese people speak
English really okay sure Yoko Ono
doesn't speak English
she's got a voice in there I bet she
speaks English you know like Wes
Anderson never end
no no goodness income no but for all of
that I kind of dug the movie but I see I
see the issues behind it how is the
aside from the issues how's the
animation lovely is it like better than
fantastic mr. Fox or it's better than
that it's you know it's it's not a
quantum leap better because it's still
going for that like handmade feel right
it's not as good as like kubu in the two
strings it's not as good as a like a
movie but it's still really strong she's
still really strong he's building a
little cottage industry of course just
Wes Anderson movies but he's got this
animation game on sighs yeah it's kind
of fascinating cartoons for smart people
hmm
I saw Krypton so the pilot for Krypto
the [ __ ] really yeah is that how it's
out it happened
it aired last week it was the third most
viewed pilot and I think of sci-fi
history or something to that what a
weird honor I know we're number three
we're number three
well that's huge man how was it given
that it's a show that doesn't really
need to exist yes I mean which could
describe many shows what you get you but
you know it's it's a little bit like
Gotham in the do I really need to see
baby Bruce Wayne like do I need to see
what Krypton is like before people can
fly Wayne Krypton is not even gonna show
you a cowl and no no but for all of that
for despite the fact that it has a
somewhat flawed premise the execution
was actually really solid like the guy
who was playing sag l that's the
grandfather
that's the grandfather you know sort of
young handsome Brit because everybody's
British on Krypton for reasons that feel
weird but okay why not he's really good
Paula malcomson is in it she's great it
looks pretty solid they they're
recasting some ideas of who the the
fabric of the Superman universe is for
example for example sag Elle's romantic
interest her last name is Zod
oh so there's a romeo giulia thing
really a thing well they're doing
everything they can to also remind you
that you know Superman is gonna show up
at some point like nine years from now
because Adam Strange spoilers is in the
pilot
that excited me very much when I saw the
commercial yeah that kind of information
that leaked he says at one point yes
range I'm a big fan of the concept of
Adam strange rant Iran's champion and
this is a guy who's got like he was
handled so well by Alan Moore years ago
I think in Swamp Thing he kidding it
he's he exists on the planet Ron for six
months at a time he could be teleported
there by the Omega being fun remember
correctly know though what is it
Thank You SATA beam Omega beam is
Darkseid
Zeta beam gets him to that place for a
period of time where he was ranch
champion Ron's champion wears the outfit
and [ __ ] like that fights the
thanagarians under breath and has like
engaged or sometimes married to the
princess of Ron but periodically the
Zeta beam wears off and he [ __ ] goes
right back to earth where he's trapped
and has to find the next location of the
Zeta beam such a great concept and could
make a very cool quasi futuristic movie
and stuff but it's nice that somebody
dug him out of mothballs and stuck him
into a show that's a cool idea yeah like
he gets to be you know the the he
provides the the Polaroid from Back to
the Future which is basically Marty when
you disappear from this picture to a
future has changed irrevocably what is
the picture it's it's Carlos cape he
comes and brings back the red cape and
says if this disappears then the future
is altered to a point of no return oh my
god I just got chills I'm about to cry
oh my god that works that [ __ ] works
really like the bottom of it the hem is
like a little drippy so it's also like
beauty in the beach the Rose that's in
the thing and they get to do that the
whole season all season she's gonna be
like look at the kid what's the Cape
doing it's [ __ ] good man
I'm in [ __ ] they show Brainiac they
do with the very tail end of it they're
like because that's ultimately the
reason why Adam Strange has to come back
to help say he'll stay on the path is
Brainiac is also traveling through time
Terminator style to kill off Clark
Kent's grandfather so that Clark never
become Superman
so this Brainiac in their world is
Brainiac from the future
come back to the past yes so he's now
like I control I'm from the I control
Krypton like it was in the cartoon he's
Superman's nemesis in the future he
comes back to the Past to kill them yeah
t1000 style I'm [ __ ] in man you did a
better job of selling it than the
trailer okay that sounds pretty dull
yeah it's like they did everything they
could to help compensate for the fact
that does anybody want a Superman show
that doesn't have Superman in it does
anybody want a no flights no tights no
guy show so let's put everything we
possibly can about Superman in it but
the minute they say fortress of solitude
like what uh yeah okay I thought this is
gonna suck but all right they do that on
Supergirl all the time they bring you to
the fortress of solitude yeah I'm super
I mean this is so gone for a few weeks
though yeah I think it's coming back
this next week or something like that
flash is also off the air for a minute
but it comes back and I think two weeks
and it's the episode that I made and Jay
and I have a bit part in the episode so
he reminded me the other days like I
just saw online that we're in the
[ __ ] flash I was like you lived it
yeah we were there it happened but yeah
they I love it on Supergirl whenever
they bring up any mythology you're like
that's the thing they'll get me just by
bringing up mythology or make a
reference or something like that
I mom but that sounds like seriously
decent storytelling it's set on the
bottle city of Kandor before is bottled
really can doors in as well that's where
it's it that's the King's Landing of
Krypton but it's not the bottle city yet
just kiss candor you know it can door
before they [ __ ] be bottles so we
know the future
oh it's free-range candor
oh my god I'm [ __ ] in it must be up
on iTunes a kebab sure yeah yeah yeah
tonight Roseanne comes back are you
excited I I'm a massive fan of that show
you know season 9 was weird but but
still there are moments in season nine
which are wonderful her winning the
lottery in the opening episode
Jackie's reaction is like one of the
best TV comedic scenes ever produced and
when they wrapped the show and she does
her monologue and talks about being a
writer and stuff like that it's
incredibly moving Dan you know they said
was dead now Dan is not dead which is
totally [ __ ] smart
you need John Goodman as Dan Connor but
it was not without its merits season 9
this seems all the press has been about
you know Roseanne Connor loves Trump and
so does Roseanne herself so I'm hoping
that the show is little more than then
kind of easy partisanship political
discourse and whatnot like I would like
it to be yeah I'm hoping it's on tonight
so I can I imagine like every show
you'll be able to download it in the
morning or something like that but I'm
looking forward to it I'm rooting for it
I always thought that was such a [ __ ]
fantastic show real slice of Americana
and a world I absolutely recognize there
was a move the reason that lasted as
long as it did and had the ratings that
it did instead so I hope to Christ they
can reconnect and do just a modern
version of that but you know right away
I'm like well they never really talked
about politics on the old one you know
there were some political situations but
like it never went into that place but
it seems like they're gonna lean on that
pretty heavily yeah I mean some of the
ads were a little troubling where it was
like ABC the family as you remember it
but look at this parade of white people
this is what family is middle America
that was my [ __ ] problem with
recognize these white people Mac ABC I
get it but especially doing a commercial
for a while on blackish oh hey I'll be
watching that and now I'm gonna watch
Krypton - I sold it man I was kind of in
the bag when they showed Brainiac but
[ __ ] man you did a much better job of
explaining that is that is what I do I
that's all we got for open a picture -
break it then it's all we got for
opening band oh my god then we're gonna
take this moment on fat man on Batman -
open the utility belt and pull out all
the news that's fit to print mark
barnard did the very heavy lifting of
reading the internet and so it's really
hard you guys we're gonna talk about the
[ __ ] that mark found take it away mark
barnard give it up for mark but armed
with the news do you remember when it
was announced like I don't know a year
ago that Donald Glover and his brother
Steven were making a Deadpool animated
show FX yes it was one of the many
things that don't Glover was attached to
that looked very cool yeah not so much
anymore though what happened
FX pulled the plug on it what yeah now
does this F X so that's Fox B she's now
gonna be Disney's have anything to do
with any of that stuff of Fox to Disney
apparently not the statement I'm sure
you can read through some of these lines
due to creative differences
FX Donald Glover Stephen Glover and
Marvel television have agreed to part
ways on Marvel's Deadpool animated
series the network said in a statement
FX will no longer be involved with the
project FX and Marvel have an ongoing
relationship through our partnership on
Legion which will continue so wait what
yeah
creative differences is what happened
what did you know down to who well he
wants to make a good show and they're
like no way or you know the the Glover
boys wanted to make a very specific show
and FX was like nah we're not doing that
aren't probably big Fox said no see
Deadpool 2 is coming out and we don't
want any competing versions of what
Deadpool is and you're going too far
astray and so over it that's my theory
is that they were they wanted to push
and explore and discover stuff I mean
you watch Atlanta you see
he's a very inquisitive storyteller and
that Atlanta is on effect so wow it's
weird for them to be like yeah we're not
gonna go forward you want to be in
business with you just not this business
with you interesting I mean I'm sure
he's happy as l-like that Atlanta shows
insanely well-versed oh yeah I mean he
won an Emmy for it and then they're not
like telling him what to do on that show
family yeah but I mean maybe it's Marvel
maybe it's FX maybe it's Fox but clearly
they were doing something that didn't
make somebody happy somebody with the
keys that's a bummer but he's so [ __ ]
busy I'm sure on some level he's just
like who a break you know he gets to
breathe and stay he's very creative and
always has like not only his own
projects like the childish gambino stuff
to work on but like people snap him up
all the time for movies now and he's got
[ __ ] lando calrissian to go out start
being when does that movie happen my
movies in like four or five weeks meant
and it says that after infinity war yeah
so infinity war is the next one or
Deadpool infinity Wars next and then
Deadpool and van and solo such a great
time to be alive all right what else we
got
speaking of Deadpool the trailer the
full trailer for Deadpool 2 came out did
you watch yes of course
look I thought the other trailer was
pretty amazing felt like a full trailer
as well but this they showed a lot more
and he actually said x-force which was
kind of cool frog and Rob Liefeld must
be like isn't Domino is is a cable his
isn't x-force's as incredible good for
him yeah I mean he's got to feel all
those pouches with something so it's all
[Laughter]
the film went it tested like it's been
screening for test audiences and
apparently did they still do that
they still do I don't even know watch a
movie like that it's like yeah do you
really have to test Deadpool to like I
imagine all you have to do is come close
to the original and ever you've made
everybody happy now they tested it
apparently I mean you have way more
experience with this than I have because
I've never made a movie nor tested
anything in front of other people but it
scored a 98 in Rio oh my god in the top
two boxes yeah that movie's gonna make
all the money top two boxes is a score
that they really care about when you do
those test screenings and that is the
combination of the scores that are
excellent and very good because
generally those people on the exit polls
also indicate that they will strongly
recommend it to friends and that believe
it or not you know it's still part of
the [ __ ] game word of mouth so that
score 98 in the top two boxes like I
think the highest I ever scored a test
screening I think we got an 89 in the
top two boxes on Jay and Silent Bob
strike back
so 98 holy [ __ ] that's ass down there
and the first one got a 91 which shows
you that this is better apparently
according to testing maybe I mean
that'll be remain to be seen but you
know now you're dealing with brand
awareness like right away going in
pepper everyone's like I this is what I
need in a Deadpool movie and it sounds
like they [ __ ] delivered on the
promise of the first one and the first
one was a promise of like here you go
here's a great movie not even like the
future looks like this just like check
it out we finally got to do this after
[ __ ] years of Fox being know so I
imagine man it's gonna not be easy to
knock it out the park but it's like just
deliver again and you got yourself a
willing audience that's just [ __ ]
ready and nobody's taking up the space
like they are in terms of like we're
still seeing a lot of superhero movies
[ __ ] you know essentially pulls his
dick out like that's the magic of that
characters so they're gonna be alone in
that [ __ ] space they're gonna own it
man I can't imagine when the next
r-rated Deadpool movies gonna be our
rated comic-book movie in general is
gonna be especially now that the Disney
Fox deal seems like it's about to go
through for reals Deadpool 2 just
underwent six days of reshoots why
they're like it's too good can we make
percent 98 [ __ ] we wanted a 95 but
apparently part of it was two hours
worth of work in LA for a secret cameo
and nobody knows what that cameo is not
Stan Lee I mean I'm sure they took care
of that if they could can't stand out
finally
well god I wonder what now again Fox
Disney deal makes this interesting is it
a Marvel Universe character a movie
universe like Marvel extended universe
or what are they calling it Marvel
Cinematic Universe maybe it's one of
those characters it would be hilarious
if at the end of Deadpool 2 he's trapped
into a box and Aaron jettisoned off the
back of a cargo plane he'll and some
more conduct was was I then that's what
I would do right they could certainly
cure that face it is another broken
white boy for them to finish Wow I
wonder what it'll be just after infinity
or yes
after it won't be Hugh Jackman it's got
to be somebody [ __ ] special like it's
got and Hugh Jackman what's special what
they kind of did a version of that
already didn't they
Patrick Stewart no I don't think it's
gonna be I don't think it's gonna be Fox
universe man I guarantee I can't
guarantee it I bet you smells like it
might be the like oh my god [ __ ] a
Marvel character a Marvel Cinematic
Universe character showed up maybe not
spider-man but [ __ ] like Robert
Downey jr. would be very at home in a
brief cameo and I'm in a Deadpool movie
what if it's Ben Grimm
I can't stand because I just came oh my
god that'd be amazing box still
technically has the Fantastic Four and
they over delivered like that would be
fantastic
either way movie sounds like a big gray
looks fantastic as yeah speaking of
Marvel Chris Evans has made it
unequivocal that he has done after
Avengers 4 yeah
yeah that is a bummer cuz he [ __ ] did
great things of that role but I honestly
feel like that has a lot to do with the
story they're telling right they're not
telegraphing it now they're [ __ ]
writing it in the sky like get ready to
lose your heroes so I think he's he's
you know his moving on isn't like I'm
[ __ ] done with this [ __ ] I think it's
right changing face of the Marvel
Universe but it's not matters tellingly
not after infinity war it's after four
it's after 4 so it seems as if cap is
not the dude who dives infinity war
unless that's just something to say to
throw us all over the scent but yeah
that's a bummer he's and he grew into
that role so well made that character
interesting and believable and stuff I
mean the key was always good right here
as good as the torch as well but boy he
did great things that character and they
surrounded him with great material but
he I will miss him in that role but it
sounds like they might like go a
different way anyway in terms of like
Steve Rogers can die somebody else can
pick up the mantle and move on they got
to capable characters in that world
already with the Falcon and [ __ ]
Bucky so I don't know that would be
ballsy and think about it
it's how satisfying that would be on a
story level of like you never got tired
of that character it was never like oh
Captain America 12 [ __ ] this [ __ ]
he looks so old he should go back in the
ice but the now it's like you'll have
fond memories of some great [ __ ]
movies and if they need that mantle to
carry over somebody else can wear it and
still be you know in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but let's be honest
they had now have a [ __ ] toy chest
full of character
that they'd even scratch from their own
IP and now they've got all the other
characters back your Fantastic Four and
your mutants and stuff like that with
the x-men world so you could just move
forward could be the some world where we
all remember Captain America oh remember
they did those movies that was before
they did the [ __ ] gambit movies
that's reaching far but you know what
I'm saying anything's possible
but there's also I mean we're living in
a science fiction construct anyway we're
there's magic and science and outer
space and aliens and Infinity stones and
nobody stays dead in science fiction
clear if somebody wants them dead
in science fiction so just because this
is the last time we see him now doesn't
mean in five years they don't crack
another Steve Rogers out of ice and say
look we found him again and he could
also like you know do cameos yeah if
they do flashbacks or something like
that or you know [ __ ] magical moments
of some sort like there's some
time-travel concerned in these Avengers
pictures aren't there now that they're
introducing Captain Marvel not enough in
infinity war but the the of not title as
yet untitled Avengers four isn't like
her character playing a role I read I'm
pretty sure I mean we have a time stone
we have we have the the built-in reason
why time can collapse on itself right
and also Coulson is gonna be in the
Captain Marvel movie I saw that he
announced that Clark Gregg and what's
his name Lee pace who played Ronan the
accuser and there's a third one from
Marvel past who German hell yeah John
and Han soo who was in the thank you Big
Daddy
oh yes yeah where's it come on man
I love that such a payoff to that joke
when I did [ __ ] third back he's like
star-lord he goes finally
but those three I mean unless they cast
him to play completely different people
which you really couldn't do with with
Colson these [ __ ] recognizable in
that world those are three characters
that are in those movies dead yep so I
guess the movie set in the 80s or
something like that eighties and
nineties 80s and 90s so I don't know
maybe that's how they bring him in or
she's going back and forth in time or
something like that however it remains
to be seen
was that that's one of my coming you get
to sign it I get to sign this one I got
one it's not do it up man so get in you
see in this mom bride hot dog for those
listening at home what is it that you
just son I signed the first graphic
novel genius it's the first arc in the
book that I'm constantly writing for Top
Cow an image yeah yoga there sadly is
one less comic book store to vend your
trade paperback I know we just all
discovered this week those of us here in
Los Angeles that perhaps one of the
greatest comic book stores that ever
lived
meltdown is closing its doors after 25
[ __ ] years man a quarter of a goddamn
century brick and mortars establishment
legendary not just for the class and
quality of books and merchandise they
could carried but for expanding
constantly like that was always
inspiring to me about that place like he
had a baby melt clothes for kids and
then of course the you know nervous
meltdown nerdmelt the nerdmelt the
theater and stuff where it became like
this [ __ ] you know backdoor comedy
club as well an incredible use of that
space and then from what I understand
from what I read it's some sort of like
they want to build a high-rise those
retail whatever that is yeah and at the
same time he's just like look just time
to move on try some other adventure or
something like that but such a great
store one that like I would always steal
ideas from and bring
- monster because I was like this
[ __ ] place is amazing and [ __ ]
sad to see her go man yeah like it was
it was a clubhouse yeah the best way
that you could go there and in much like
scum and villainy you went and you found
your people and your people were there
and they were reading comics or buying
comics they were listening to comedy and
podcasts and all kinds of amazing stuff
and they loved books and they loved
people who created books know people who
read books yeah like it's it's sad to
see it go it is it's a bummer so they've
opened until what I think it's like
April till Friday so if you're here in
town you got a chance to walk in and
help them out buy some stuff to empty
out their stock last chance to see a
great place pop cultural hallmark man
it's really a shame that they're going
away golden apples still around though
don't forget you know Melrose Golden
Apple still here both of them were I
remember like Golden Apple in the 90s
like they created a character flaxen who
was like their kind of logo and there's
a book like comic book series based on
the character and what I liked about
meltdown is they created their own logo
guy - that alien-looking character I
always thought that was great now as I
was telling [ __ ] Walter Flanagan we
need a little mascot for Jay and Silent
Bob's secret stash he's like Jay and
Silent Bob or the mascot and thought
about that what else we got Frank Miller
is still making comics what's more he
just signed a five project deal with DC
good to make more comics for them one of
which will be a Carrie Kelly why a
miniseries oh [ __ ] that's fantastic yeah
yau said yeah he wants to it's right
Miller's gonna write for tweens well you
know we'll see how that goes but yeah
Miller will be writing our young readers
graphic novel starring Carrie Kelly will
be illustrated by Ben Caldwell who I'm
not sure and he's also doing a Superman
year one and a Batman year one now we
redid it
ya mean we all read that but yeah I mean
[ __ ] the Carrie Kelly thing is enough
yeah that's very big news like Robin
from him again I'll take it and that
character who they you know he's she's
been in all his dark nights but we'd go
tons of places they've never really
explored that character a good time with
Carrie Kelly I met not in a dirty I just
haven't liked that character spawn as
[ __ ] and to do a why a book makes a lot
of sense yeah a whole ton of sense what
else we got
there's gonna be a ROM space night movie
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
wow I mean there was a common Marvel
comic that was huge back in the day the
toy itself was a little boring
I never haven't even asked for it as a
child but the comic book series that
came out of it I remember was had a huge
fandom who's doing it Allspark pictures
which is Hasbro's movie producing arm
okay and it's being written by Zack Penn
oh he co-wrote ready play ready to play
one and the first Avengers and expend
three and created alphas and he sold his
first script at 23 years old which was
last American Last Action Hero
that's right man that was I remember he
was one of the what do they call that
spec script kids made a lot of money for
that for that idea yeah I met him once
he wrote the Hulk right mm-hm
I met him once as Battlestar Gallactica
panel he was real nice but yeah and he's
written some some really good [ __ ] ya
know he's he's one of those guys that
Nollywood turns to when they want to do
John Roos stuff right he's in the midst
of writing a film set in the matrix
world for Warner Brothers oh so a matrix
equal that the Mushaf skis are not
involved in write sequel reboot reboot
concurrent story whatever that is he's
been very mum on it although he did say
once in a quote like if I was going to
cast buzz guidry cast Keanu Reeves I'd
cast Keanu Reeves so it's not like
they're trying to redo the matrix it's
like no he's that character will still
exist as we know him oh that's good this
is just another story in that world in
world yeah remember we talked I guess
last week about the men in black movie
yeah Chris Hemsworth is starring in yes
very Chris Hemsworth that I pitched
Tiffany Haddish to be his his shotgun
rider and Marc [ __ ] Paul I remember
that they didn't go that way
they went with Tessa Thompson oh that's
a good grade too
yeah oh wow she's funny as well it's a
regular young Thor movie and I met her
in real life interviewing people for
IMDB up at Sundance and she was real
like witty and sharp yeah she's smart
cat know so yeah that is happening now I
think again they're not touching on J
and K although it's not a reboot LaRose
characters will have existed in the
world these are just new agents for the
men in black I love it eventually they
get a Will Smith cameo at this point why
not with a cast that cool I'm sure he'll
be like if he's on Instagram learning
how to salsa dance with Marc Anthony I'm
sure he will show up to get paid that
what he's up to
he's like living his best life at almost
50 good for him and he had all that
trouble in Philadelphia as a child what
else we got astro city is coming to
television oh that's a good [ __ ] idea
who's doing that FremantleMedia right
now good idea Kurt Busiek right [ __ ] I
love that series that was good
boy that you could do a whole anthology
series yeah I mean that's that's the
trick of that yeah you know it's tied
together by the location you know and
characters do sort of weave in and out
and recur here and there but finding
what that show is unless it's gonna be
like the twilight zone anthology set in
the twilight zone and that's astro city
right
that's a that's a tough nut to crack but
I'm so glad somebody's trying to crack
it I agree a good source material like
you know in a world where you know I'm
happy somebody's gonna get a raw movie
but that does that you know [ __ ] give
me a chubby at all but here in this I'm
like oh [ __ ] that could be interesting
yeah so Gregory Novak who used to be DC
films as guy before DC we had an
expanded universe
like he was a producer unread back when
there was a random oh yeah way back when
that was a comic book movie yeah is
executive producing and boozy ik is
writing he's co-writing the pilot
himself [ __ ] a which is great I'm on
board for that
ya know home for it just Fremantle's
making it and then they'll sell it yeah
they don't have a network for the cats
that make the Neil Gaiman show American
Gods right right so they have lots of
money to spend there in the comic book
business people are smart to be so not
just like superheroes but like there's
some brilliant [ __ ] books out there
that you know great source material for
ongoing series I mean think about it
they were ongoing so yeah that's the nut
that's what it is it's serial
storytelling look we've been doing it
for 75 years yeah borrow some of this
[ __ ] and the last story is not quite the
nicest of stories or at least it's it's
a little bit of a downer but that's okay
is this me - no not me - although I
there was a trailer that broke for this
mr. Rogers documentary called like won't
you be my neighbor yes and I saw that
Mister Rogers was trending and like no
not mr. Rogers he didn't do anything bad
it can my childhood his innocence still
I'm just dread every time I see somebody
who trending I'm like not that guy
please not that guy people like we've
slowed down the recordings and if you
listen to him if real close he says
won't you [ __ ] me neighbor
[Laughter]
no he's by all reports of [ __ ] Saints
on earth and that trailer just makes you
ashamed to be a human being that's not
as beauteous as as the soul of [ __ ]
Fred Rogers goddamn what is the movie
call won't you be my name when's it come
out summer June I think I mean that's a
movie that could do it's a documentary
of course but I could do legit business
especially like a time like now it's
nice to see somebody be so heroic by
simply being kind and [ __ ] caring and
stuff you watch that trailer you can't
help but tear up dudes seem like a
seriously [ __ ] decent individual yeah
there was this clip I saw online I've
got shoes it's not new but it was Fred
Rogers testifying in front of Finance
Committee in the government
where they're about to shut down
children's program yeah QED in
Pittsburgh or whatever and he goes and
he sits opposite you know that meanest
grumpiest like cartoonishly cliched
senators like I don't know children so
they also happen to be the panel of
judges from Flashdance that was one guy
blowing his nose and [ __ ] and it was up
to the Fred Rogers to impress them all
dump water on it
sorry I just rewatched Flashdance I mean
I don't need to say anymore that's
exactly what that was but he verbal
equivalent the emotional the equip
motional given and in the seven minutes
of this clip you see Fred Rogers dish
off the dome convinced a senator to fund
public television and children's
programming because he's telling them
why he why it's worth talking to
children in this way why it's worth not
just having cartoons and not just having
what passes for educational
entertainment again this was the 50s
yeah it was him saying that you know
treating children as emotional beings
and understanding that they feel the
same things that we feel without the
tools that we have to navigate those
feelings is important and what we're
doing is we're arming children to
navigate the world that they're gonna
live in and talking to them as people
and treating them as people and and not
spending a fortune but it's good work
and it's worth doing so that when awful
things in the world happen they have the
language to describe what they're
feeling that they have the ability to to
reckon with their own way in the world
how come nobody does that anymore
like not commercial enough like like
everyone I think about Mister Rogers
neighborhood I think about one of the
most watched children's programming of
all time programs of all time but not
heavily merchandise there wasn't a
lockdown of Mister Rogers merchandise he
didn't seem interested in selling the
show he just wanted to have it exist but
I mean I meant on cardigans alone but I
mean I think Sesame Street you know sort
of also stood in that Lane of let's talk
about divorce let's talk about death
let's talk about really wrongful
commercialised they were is a wonderful
show but they were like and you could
buy an Oscar the Grouch it's right but I
didn't really do that with mr. Ravi yeah
because I think his show was super cheap
like it was literally I'm in I'm in one
tiny studio space and it built this
model of a town with my hands and we
have a puppet and I wear a hat in a
cardigan and that's it it's true all the
sets remain the same I think from the
beginning so they amortize their costs
week or something like that and then
just use the same set over they asked me
what does it cost to make your show it's
like well it costs us about two thousand
dollars a year yeah that's it and
everyone in the business was Lucille
Ball's on the phones and I got to keep
myself in Cubans know but now that just
that clip is amazing and the idea that
there will be a documentary that kind of
explores the world and the life of Fred
Rogers I cannot wait that is not the
story that I'm talking about that I said
though Oh William mention of Loubs
remember that guy of course I do he
wrote if you like the flash TV show you
have to like and an Oh a debt to William
Messinger Lopes he worked on flash in
the 80s and 90s and a lot of the
storylines and characters that they used
on that show come from his stuff when I
first watched my very first episode of
the flash the one that had the King
shark appearance at the like it was
season 2 episode 1 or 2 and King shark
made his first appearances like at the
tail end and when I watched it up Jason
muses best like my first takeaway was
this plays exactly like a bill Messner
Loubs issue of Flash like how charming
how wonderful and stuff so yeah he was
writing when I was collecting and
reading very ardently yeah Wonder Woman
he created Artemis yeah for Wonder Woman
yeah he is currently homeless on the
streets of Detroit I read that story
it's a bummer and and the idea I mean
comics is an art form that I love it's a
medium that I love
but it has traditionally never been good
to those who make it yeah you know for
every you know Stanley friend I mean
Jack Kirby had to sue for rights back I
mean simon & schuster absolutely had to
go to war with DC and Warner Brothers to
get their names back on the books that
son and Shuster seagull seagull on
Shuster Simon & Schuster yeah anybody
you know like there's there is a long
history of the people who built the
worlds that we now enjoy and that way
that other people profit mainly off of
ya do not get to share in any of that in
fact they are now destitute in many ways
and then the industry is coming around
in the same way that the NFL used to
just abandon players to the vagaries of
time and guys with massive brain
injuries and broken knees and powdered
spines or just trying to you know get
food comic says the charity pines is a
[ __ ] evocative term thank you
but yeah comics for as much as we love
comics sometimes comics does not love
you back how can we help bill muster
Loubs I think that that it was it was a
new story that aired on on Fox in
Detroit and I think that in the wake of
that story people are beginning to rally
and beginning to get him you know
housing and beginning to get him aid and
hopefully putting him back to work you
know I mean there's no reason why that
dude can't still write there's no reason
why that mean he's an amazing one-armed
artist you read this story too and he's
like he's had the life of [ __ ] joke
man like the series of unfortunate
events that leads to his homelessness is
not like oh he was [ __ ] wild party
doll with all his money away and [ __ ]
like that not at the least a lot of
sickness there as well and Bill has one
arm for an correctly but you know
there's no like pension for doing comics
it is it is like you either save your
money or do you just leave it up to the
fates there's one charity what is Jim
McLaughlin's charity your own issue
didn't they hear initiative yeah Jim put
together has been
distance I think at least maybe ten
years at this point where that they
raise money for the comp of creators of
old who have fallen on hard times right
so I mean it seems as if he's getting
some help and it seems as if he's not
going to be living in a car on the
streets of Detroit anymore but you know
just to be aware that that for many of
the people who built the foundations for
our current for our present it is not
quite as rosy for them as it is for us
and it's also not as uncommon as story
as you would imagine as well yeah a lot
of people who wrote your favorite [ __ ]
created your childhood memories
don't walk away with the financial
wealth that you walk away with these you
know emotional wealth of reading those
stories where is this Detroit Detroit
you know and marvel to their credit like
they've absolutely started you know
funneling money back especially when
characters are featured in movies and
they realized that okay that if for no
other reason than just PR but it's also
because there are decent people who run
that staff are beginning to feed money
back into the pockets of the people who
create others characters but you know I
don't know how much that is I don't know
how much it does but you know if you
find yourself in a place where the hero
initiative is raising money you know
throw a shekel in maybe we care the like
auction like one of my flash jerseys or
something like that raised bunch of
bucks as well
that's all the news that's fit to print
that is all the news we have my friend
was it bummer story to go yeah we got it
we got a guest though we do we do have a
guest man so last week we had a guest
this week we have a guest on the show we
don't basically I respond to passion and
whoa that kind of passion those like
let's break the glass we just got
married kind of passion and this our
guest reached out about being on the
show because it's a fan of the show but
more importantly it's a big Batman fan
like and you know the show is called
Batman I'm Batman and we so rarely
talked about the Dark Knight anymore and
stuff so I felt like this was great
let's bring this cat on he is the lead
singer in a band called the Black Veil
Brides is that correct and you're coming
you're gonna have to come this way
oh really mo there hey give it up for
and is Biersack yourself give it up for
Andy Biersack ladies and gentlemen we
had a conversation in the alley
beforehand I'm going like it's bie our
sack it's gotta be like it's
phonetically like it's Pierce a possible
way to pronounce it I went to Catholic
school and they didn't want to pronounce
it correctly so they told my my name was
burrs AK growing up they took your
[ __ ] business like yeah the hate of
the beer you could understand like ball
sack was real easy for like you know the
bullies and everything but I fear sack
that's the name oh my god that's right
you got an attack ballsack probably yeah
III feel like my wife said like in
earnest when we got married that she
wanted to take the name and then I was
like don't do that don't go this is like
you and your sack I'm doing it in all
right so where are you from sir I'm from
Cincinnati Cincinnati in the great state
of Ohio yeah
apparent as we said your name you heard
a bunch of people go whoo and you have a
big social media following stuff music
[ __ ] seems to be working out pretty well
yes so far I mean it's I've been very
fortunate I'm in a rock band in 2018
it's a little bit like going into an
Apple store and trying to sell somebody
a record you know what I mean like it's
gonna be like it's an Elfa moded kind of
antic wipes playing that why why I don't
know cuz rock is sort of seen as like
the movie Rock of Ages right the punch
line is the idea of rock music like yeah
remember Rock and that's sort of like
the whole thing that we are fighting
against as rock musicians is trying to
make people realize that the idea the
innate idea of like rebellion and
everything else like that still builds
within but for outcasts and losers and
kids like me rock is still the thing you
know it's it means just as much to me as
I understand like hip hop and
everything's really popular but rock
music to us is the thing that kind of
turns us on and I'm still something
irresistible about you know a power
chord yeah you know like you can't quite
get away from the magnetic quality of
look that's kind of amazing and you
don't get that so that's your power
chord impression Gong ringing man I
didn't want to go like fuzz fuzz is
weird on the microphone would it be more
like me
without there's a British magazine
called Kerrang and it's a really it's
been around for years and years and I
asked that or one time why it's called
that and he said because that's the
noise a guitar makes it isn't like I
know whereabouts Krang it's not it's the
name of a Ninja Turtles villain but it's
not excellent
what year were you born sir 1994 years
before we made clerks okay so what your
childhood heroes I understand read
someplace you saw kiss
yeah I saw kiss in a Batman mask or gene
Simmons well no so I was my introduction
to rock music came from Batman
essentially so I I was introduced to
Batman by my dad when I was really young
the Adam West TV series he had bootleg
VHS as I watched him I was kid and when
I saw the old kiss 70s trading cards I
saw gene Simmons which is essentially a
Batman logo on his face and I thought oh
those are superheroes of some kind and
so that was kind of my introduction to
rock music was assuming that kiss was
superheroes which you weren't all that
wrong they did the Marvel comic at one
point absolutely they were supers and
kiss meets the fan of the park they were
in total [ __ ] soup there could be
worse things for like a little kid who
loves the idea of like costumery and
pageantry than like this band I like has
comic books and movies about them it was
like I don't know for me everything does
come back to Batman though like that was
my main thing so who's your Batman so it
was so how weird like he built this
whole career and at the center of it
that's not even about Batman but at the
center of video like yeah man Batman's
what kind of made me want to yes I was I
was a like like many people that end up
in rock bands I was a kind of loner
you know nerd I I didn't do well in
school I wasn't very popular but I
thought of myself as like this I could
create this version of myself that it's
all the things that I'm afraid of and
presented on stages like the rock star
guy and that was the biggest inspiration
for me with all of comic books was these
kind of characters that particularly the
ones that didn't have superpowers that
took elements of their fears innings
and things that they wanted to be and
turn themselves into that so that was
like the coolest thing for me and I
think I realized as I got older that one
of the reasons why I like Batman so much
was that kind of level of you know it's
it's a guy who while yes he's a
billionaire and in a much better
situation but most of us it's a person
turning their fears on on their head and
making themselves into it I mean Batman
is nothing if not theatrical like yeah
built into the DNA of who Batman is I
mean he's born in the back of a theater
although he's kind of a loser as a
person like he doesn't know how to talk
to other people really and he sucks with
really [ __ ] parents birth right
I just means like loser he lost his
parents the trauma yeah understandably
so but I just mean in the sense that I
felt an association with him in that way
Tim Burton was the same way man right
look his old take on Batman was like
he's the ultimate outsider you talked
about like building the onstage persona
Gerard Way talked about the same thing
like he was a comic-book kid as well
worked in a comic book store and then
when My Chemical Romance happened he was
like I get to build a character and go
up and be the character of like a rock
star yeah you know but like when I'm
done I go home read my comics and stuff
like that as that seems to be a part of
rock and roll more than anything else is
there's still showman it's about a show
you're putting on a show it's not as
simple as we're gonna get up here and
[ __ ] sing yeah there is some salary
to it yeah I think I think one of the
things like for my band anybody that if
at some points you go who the hell was
that Tim Burton character standing
you'll see a lot of lipstick and makeup
and the whole thing and a lot of that is
just the idea of creating that kind of
like that's your costume that's your
that's your armor that you're going
onstage with and it's putting on a show
you know I think that one of the reasons
why when I look at like the hip-hop
culture one of the reasons why I love
current hip-hop so much is that there is
art and there's a culture to it and
there's intriguing there's fashion all
this it's just that the music for me
isn't what I grew up loving as much I
want and I would hope that rock stars
and stuff well you know I mean Gerard is
a great example of a person who's so
multifaceted and is intelligent and
presented so much and is a great comic
book writer and I just you know for me
that's that's kind of the reason why I
got into rock music is is obviously the
pageantry of it but also just the kind
of escapism you know like this so has so
many drudgery
the idea of like riding a hard rock
record and singing along with something
loud in your car like it's fun is you're
about 12 years old now yes 15 yeah 27 27
so when did you start music and when did
you feel like like we're out of place
you know you some people like you ask
hey what did you feel like you made it
and they're like I'm still waiting but
when did you get to a place where like
I'm [ __ ] safe I could be me I don't
have to do another job I don't have to
work for some other [ __ ] this is who
I can be for a living and stuff how long
between when the dream begins the
journey begins and that moment happens
or has that moment not had that it's a
multi-faceted substantial things of like
were you on I have a house you know that
kind of things you're you go like oh now
you know I'm not I'm not living
month-to-month but for me like I dropped
out of high school I I moved out here
from Ohio with nothing I lived in the
back of my car
86 Cadillac Eldorado just trying to make
it so for me it was I had no other
options I kind of threw everything else
away and said I have to do this well
what does one do in that instance like
you're an actor you come out in your
auditioning [ __ ] what are you doing
as just playing gigs I like eggs yeah I
lived in my car in a rehearsal studio
space and I don't know if you remember
the band wasp from the 80s
wasp [ __ ] yeah so the guitar player and
that bands again in Chris home nobody's
mentioned wasp to me and like a decade I
just got warm memories of my [ __ ] yeah I
remember was blankie lies right well yes
so the guitar player in that band was
most notably in the decline of Western
civilization he's floating in a pool
spitting vodka or add himself I lived in
a rehearsal space parking lot it was a
lockout cuz you could park in 24 hours
and it turns out that so did he my first
friend and the person that I met he had
a space where he was building guitars
out of trees and she'd need come over
and bring me bags of ice just randomly
like hey or an Alice Cooper kid and he'd
bring me a bag of ice huh and we became
friendly that way and so I started to
meet other people at the rehearsal space
people that also had long black hair and
wore eyeliner like me and it kind of
like started jamming and then it was
just about playing as often as possible
we couldn't get shows here at first like
we couldn't get shows at the whiskey and
all those places that people want to
apply is a super
yeah cuz it's all pay to play like you
have to be able to sell X amount of
tickets to play at those places so we
didn't have any fans or friends it was
hard to sell tickets so we would play
like skate shops parking a lot of skate
shops and stuff and yeah we were able to
work our way up that way so wait when
you came out here you didn't have a band
yet I had I had well kind of so in
Northern Kentucky Lexington a tea area I
had started a variation of the band and
I told everybody when I turn 18 I move
in LA we're all gonna go and we would
all yeah we're all gonna go to LA and
then the day came and nobody came with
me so yeah come on guys yeah I had to
start over again so when he came here
that's when he found the people who
would be in Black Veil Brides yes yeah
yeah because of the wasp guy no it was
just that was the first person that I
had met and able to make connections
through you know meeting him meant okay
well now there's another guitar player
who's there who would maybe take this
essentially this eighteen year old kid
seriously is living in his car oh well
you know that person and kind of
connecting that way but I I met everyone
kind of in a very organic way where I
met a guitar player and then he
introduced me to a bass player and he
introduced me to a drummer and then we
would start touring and touring and
carbons all like-minded individuals like
I like that music too yeah I mean being
in a bands weird right cuz like the only
there's no you don't know anything about
the people that you're in a band with
you go I like Black Sabbath you like
Black Sabbath that's the whole basis and
then you're on tour and you're in Idaho
together you're like holy [ __ ] you hate
cats a lot like whatever weird random
that you find out about some money
ultimately you kind of it's like a
really weird arranged marriage but
fortunately I'm happy that the four
people I've been in a band with for the
last ten years of our nice friends of
mine is that what happened to the
Beatles John found out Paul hated cats
yeah every major band is alright wait so
you've come to Hollywood at 18 and now
you're 27 how long has the band been
like poppin Wow how many years terms are
doing well or
I mean maybe in the last I mean it took
off probably around 2010-2011 was when
things started going really well so how
old were you so that's alright let's do
the reverse math seven years ago yeah
28 him out in when you were 18 and
you're 27 I said you only have to try
for two [ __ ] years so I thought this
is a story about paying dues I had all
right well yeah I mean honestly
thankfully it did take off when I was
here but I had toured I started to when
I was 16 regionally all through oh [ __ ]
you're one of those people yes I was
with older guys in bands none of them
came with me here so I had to restart
but I already had a name and people that
were kind of fans ish and thankfully at
that point we had things like MySpace
where you could put songs up and there
were people who were interested in that
so see you social media to build it up
and stuff yeah absolutely
now you still do solo stuff in addition
to Black Veil Brides yeah yeah I was I
was very interested in doing like I
guess kind of Depeche Mode Bauhaus like
kind of goth music oh I thought I didn't
want to be the guy who's like now hey
we're like a glam heavy metal band but
check out the goth records so I wanted
to kind of you know I wanted to do
something separate and and thankfully I
was able to do that and people responded
to it all right so that's the career and
the career is predicated on a talent of
course and a willingness apparently to
[ __ ] go out here believe in yourself
[ __ ] that's a story about like really
believe in but you knew you had the year
let me ask you this like when people go
like oh my god did you know it would
happen you did know didn't you yeah yeah
not in a way of like arrogant like [ __ ]
of course it's gonna happen because I'm
talented but what were your options like
you literally left home behind to
[ __ ] live in a car in Los Angeles
clearly you were single-minded with
purpose but people don't do that
like unless they feel like they can see
the future like they knew it was [ __ ]
happening did you know that was gonna
happen like I watched a tape I made that
I gave to my parents for I went to film
school and I was like 20 I just played
it on SModcast it's [ __ ] hysterical
because I'm so earnest and [ __ ] so
serious and you're like this guy made
clerks but in any event
telling them exactly what's gonna happen
and I'm kind of right in about 98% of
the way I say that I'm never probably
gonna live with them again that wasn't
true I wound up moving back home one
more time but other than that like I
kind of called it and it's weird when I
listen to it now because I'm like and I
watch the tape I'm like oh my god like
this kid had an idea and I don't know if
it was just like he was foolish enough
to be leave like this will work out
things always work out or if he actually
believed it like I owe a lot to that
goofy [ __ ] kid who believed in
himself when like I from where I stand
looking back I'm like why did he believe
in himself and sure but did you know
that it was gonna happen yeah I mean I
think I think that there's a certain
level of like insufferable that you act
like I'm an only child and I had no
friends so I was just basic oh my god
that's the perfect welcome Louis II made
a wrong story all the time like I would
have them take the camcorder and I would
make them read interviews that I had
written for myself that I had answers
for my future as a big rock star like
you know my mom would and Andy so now
that you're the biggest rock star in the
world well thank you very much mom I am
I know this was going to happen so yeah
I mean I guess in that way I I just
really wanted it you know I wanted to be
that guy on the stage I wanted to get to
do this so the only way I knew how to do
it being from Ohio was just to come out
here and try [ __ ] that worked
alright so Batman I saw a picture of you
online for a birthday dressed up in
Batman regalia it is young birthday
correct yeah how old was Batman every
year so I mean up until the last year
that I was Batman was 2012 and it ended
really badly I wore a a Adam West bat
suit and I can't smoke weed and or some
yeah alright it's not it's not a it's
not a judgmental thing I have a physical
reaction right and so we all do we get
high yeah sure
like I get my kite vomit and oh that's
not good so I but many times in my life
I have been faced with the situation
where I particularly when I was younger
I would say but surely that's not true I
can definitely smoke weed it's all on
your mind and then I would vomit and so
it was Halloween 2012 I'm wearing the
bat suit and again one of those
opportunities came up where someone said
hey Andy would you like to smoke some
weed and I said yes I would
and then I smoked weed and then I
vomited all on the inside of the Batsuit
filled it it was a like for a bat suit I
filled it boy did you pull it out and
puke in do you yeah well because I had
the mask I'm at work and it's just kind
of like down the neck oh I was in the
middle of a street on in downtown and my
wife was dressed as the Julie Newmar
Catwoman and she had to drag me back to
we live downtown at the time our home
and dress his Catwoman with heels and
vomit the the toilet broke and all the
vomit came up on her so she had like a
shitty vomity bats or cat suit on that
was my last Halloween that was the last
one that I dressed up as Batman story
that I hear out of that whole story is
you got to try weed again judgey on it
or next to you just go as a bag of vomit
and just cut out the middleman yeah
exactly
holy [ __ ] how charming all right so
Batman been a big part of your life if
you were born in 90 who's your first
Batman what's your first bath oh my god
nightfall Batman with the [ __ ] robot
suit and [ __ ] that was my first like my
dad buying me comics bringing home I
have a tattoo on my arm of authorial
Batman I'm a big ass yeah it's under
let's see it's not gonna take it off
take it off when did you get it what
year it's right there holy [ __ ] man you
got a I got a creature of jean-paul
Valley doesn't have him tattoos I just
me just me and my dad has old-school
like regular
like Neal Adams Batman on his arm yeah
in the same place did you guys go
together
yeah yeah I was like 16 when I got it
I'm just gonna take this up are you
[ __ ] me so you were like dad I want
to tattoo a Batman he's like well only
if I get one yeah my dad actually has
such a rock star that was such a rock
star movie literally put the mic in up
like Batman tattoos as do i he's the one
who introduced me to it so my dad was in
bands and stuff when I was a kid and
he'd traveled a little bit and when he
would come back he would bring me comic
books so that was my real my first
Batman comic was the one that was
introducing Azrael where there was the
fold cover where it had him you know
regular Batman the no a new badge o
Kesava cover right yes so that that was
my first introduction to the character
and I didn't really like that version of
the character because I'm not a pacifist
but my interest in Batman was more about
like the angst and the brood and not
like the you know the daggers in
people's eyes and all that kind of hues
I'm fighting the urge to be an assassin
and yeah yeah it was a little confusing
for me as like a five-year-old you know
it's do or like st. Dumas and I was like
I have no idea what does have to do with
Batman that I'm watching like Val Kilmer
and then I looked down at my comics and
I'm like this doesn't compute it was a
good story so were you
like when nightfall and it became like
it was a nightfall night quest in
Knights end and then Knights end so were
you happy when [ __ ] Bruce Wayne came
back we're baffled like who is this old
man ya know I was into it I didn't love
like the the weird anatomically correct
bat suit that he wore to like what the
face to come back where he was yeah that
was weird but everything I mean I
enjoyed the whole story I've always
loved Dick Grayson like I loved his part
in that him
Batman shortly and I don't know for me
like that's my nostalgia book I go back
to him all the time
when you first got that book did you go
backwards to be like who is Azrael and
by like sort of Azrael the miniseries
and [ __ ] were they a little bit I mean I
was a kid so I was I was more just in
the moment like you know getting it
every week and seeing what was happening
next and all the shadow of the bad and
all the different storylines that were
going on do you remember the John Paul
Valley Batman vaguely robotic suit no
skin on the face like a full face mask
and stuff I just it wasn't my Batman
what is this [ __ ] well but they did
like a gradient into it which I find
funny because they started where he had
the bat suit yeah but he wore the claws
and then he slowly went like which
actually to be fair is like you know I
never saw it as like this is stupid I'm
like why wouldn't you wear yeah [ __ ]
body armor pervious yeah Ben Affleck
certainly did I saw him talking on some
clip online I guess it was during the
Justice League junket and he was he said
because I remember watching that movie
one thing stuck out to me was how he
when he's wearing the final suit in the
third act like he looks like the Stay
Puft Marshmallow Man
he also vomited in his suit Justice
League but he he said in the interview
that like they keep adding things to the
suit and the biggest like challenge in
being Batman is to just hold your arms
naturally because like that yeah it
really I felt bad for him after I saw
that cuz I thought that was him just
being a job yeah he can't put his hands
together like if you fought this Batman
in the real world you would totally win
because he's just like yeah well the
thing they keep adding to the suit is
meatball sandwiches it's not like it's
like who's been is adding to his belly
do you think so
you didn't look that's felt he didn't he
never took his shirt off in Justice
League the way he did in Batman I don't
know if too heavy guys are allowed to
judge a thin person like that
childhood manner though I'll allow it
alright so Batman is your thing and and
and was a since childhood where else do
you go with it in the world of Batman uh
what do you mean like in comic books are
just in handa more ever take us on a
Batman I don't know I I was I guess as a
kid I was I was heavily into just kind
of the DC world I'm it's not any like
slide against Marvel when I was a kid
that was just the thing I gravitated
towards was the more kind of really
monolith you know the kind of mythology
behind all the Alex Ross paintings I was
a kid had a big effect on me and seeing
that kind of like oh these are like a
realistic representation of yeah of
course could be real yeah and it was
always like he would be the guy that
would make a Superman suit and have his
friend wear it so that he had a life
model right there was not guesswork he
found real people to wear those suits so
[ __ ] brilliant
and I love that art like I loved Kingdom
Come for that reason being able to see
all of his art and then obviously when
he started doing more books but that was
he will always be my favorite artist
just cuz I loved that representation of
the characters the when you go out in
the world and do press like when you're
doing your day job it gets to speak for
itself what do you imagine you have to
go out and [ __ ] do in a reuse and
[ __ ] like that do you talk about comic
book fandom you talk about like oh my
god I love this character a blah blah
blah or you mostly talk about the music
I don't know how it goes in that I mean
it really depends I'm very open about my
my interest in comics and particularly
Batman obviously I mean I have a lot of
Batman's you know it's kind of a dead
giveaway so people do ask me about it a
lot it's always like when you do like a
jokey interview right like so what's
your favorite blood but and then that's
always some sort of Batman related thing
but I do talk about it a lot you know I
try I try to because to me all right so
I went to Batman vs Superman and I was
and I'm standing I'm sitting next to a
little kid who's got his action figures
and he's waiting to see Batman and the
joy of seeing Batman and then he watched
that movie and I thought that's me
through a Batman suit
it's not a criticism of the movie
entirely it's just the entire lack of
joy that's in that movie and how I don't
want particularly for like we have
younger fans the character represents so
much and brings so much joy and hope and
and it's so interesting to me that I if
I as a guy who sings in a rock band who
wears a bunch of makeup whatever else
like if I can say hey go read this comic
book or or look into the character and
this way and don't just look at it as
like Jacques MMA fighter guy who is mad
about everything like that's just not
that's not the character to me it just
my god that's kind of what it was well
yeah he was dragging that tire and he
was stupid pissed it doesn't feel like
it represents me at all if for why I
love the character because it doesn't
feel like an outsider it feels like the
bully you know oh it's such a great
point it was weird because it sure
looked the most like the character we've
ever seen in the movie but I don't know
if we wanted that I thought I did and
then I saw it I was like oh no I wanted
the gray suit so much and I'm like oh
it's just pajamas now like that's true
they took all the [ __ ] shirt shirt
you know at the end of the day I think
those movies are flawed but I think they
are pretty fascinating it's one person's
tonal take on material that I was very
familiar with laid out over and over
again in the same way and this person
whether like because that's how they
read these books or whether they're like
well I want to put my spin on it took
those characters in completely different
directions than I'd ever seen before and
it's not always bad it's just different
stuff but that being said I hear what
you're saying it's tough to show a kid I
would imagine I haven't had to do that
but you know an 8-year old Batman V
Superman and be like don't worry they'll
stop talking soon and I swear they're
both heroes even though they [ __ ]
hate each other and stuff and I swear
they're both there you just can't see
because it's real dark on the screen is
that there will be something for another
filmmaker to react to yeah so that the
next iteration of these things will be
polar opposite of what we got that time
I think we saw movement already we
Justice League you know the elements
that are in there at least at least
there's fun in it I mean I think what we
all had at least if from my perspective
of like the the fandom of that character
we really wanted what we got in the
Nolan movies and then we all went like
oh all the other superheroes are having
fun now and our guys just really serious
and real and I think everybody was
excited to see maybe a little bit of the
fantasy get put in to the Batman world
and I just think Batman vs Superman
wasn't fantastic enough where as Justice
League like I can deal with the
one-liners and everything else and I
know Batman doesn't make any sense in
that context but that's kind of the joy
of like he really doesn't want to be
here and that's always been kind of a
fun part of him being in the Justice
League but I think even going obviously
it's a slippery slope Rekha's then
you're heading towards Schumacher world
so like I don't know it's like hey man
be happy yeah I don't know maybe we're
just forever gonna do this we're gonna
get gritty and then too gritty and then
we're gonna get really bright and then
over and over again it forever for me
it's like look as many times they want
to hand out that character like in
comics he's been written by a bunch of
people not just one person and stuff you
know some people are gonna have takes
for you're like oh my god I [ __ ] like
just like I've read a lot of Justice
League
comic books over the course of my life
my favorite Justice League comics were
written by Grant Morrison don't mean I
don't like the other ones but when I
[ __ ] think about a lot of Justice
leading how good it could be it was in
the hands of that creator so in the case
of like Batman with Nolan clearly that
character clicked and sanely well with
that creator in the case of Zack Snyder
sometimes it clicked well visually you
can't [ __ ] beat it it [ __ ] that [ __ ]
looks like an Alice well Alex Ross
painting most of the time tonally though
it was often in some places and stuff so
I look forward to the next iteration I
look looks like it's Matt Reeves and
we'll get a Batman again but they don't
seem to be racing toward it man like and
I'm just you know they're gonna cuz
that's where the money is but I guess
it's more important to keep Wonder Woman
going now that the the pup has been
primed it made a bunch of money and
everyone's like we like that more of
that and [ __ ] like that I mean take a
beat take a pause reset put your house
in order and then get back to work make
the new gods instead bless you alright
so for those here in the room and
those listening you know yeah [ __ ] you
got an inspiring story already and as
much as like you had a vision you did it
now you're [ __ ] rock star holy [ __ ]
how do you get there how does that work
for people who are like I'd like to do
that maybe not the exact same thing but
[ __ ] I want to be the person I want it
to be at age 16 like that's [ __ ]
rarefied air you're breathing man a lot
of us you know if I want if I was who I
wanted to be at age 16 I'd be a serial
masturbator
but uh but a lot of us don't have a
[ __ ] dream that like we could carry
through short into adulthood my I'm
still could if you want that's me that's
there for you god damn it but no I'm
building toward it but like not everyone
gets to do that that's breathing
rarefied air for those who are
interested in that sort of thing we're
like I want to be like my snot my 16
year old self but I want to do the thing
that made me passionate at this age for
the rest of my [ __ ] life how do they
get there because you [ __ ] did it
well it sounds cliche but I think the
biggest thing and you know this is work
I mean honestly it's there is there's a
stigma attached to doing too much and
people get like worried about getting
exhausted when it comes to this and I
think in this town especially people
like oh I'm so overworked but the
reality is until you get to the point
where you can sit back you have to be
willing to do everything that's put in
front of you and that makes you kind of
uncomfortable for a while but for me I
wanted to do something that is
essentially a non job that allows for me
to prance around in tight pants and eye
makeup for a living so I was doing take
your shirt off in these proceedings as
well those boys if you get to that yeah
if you get to the point where that
you're allowed to do that at work why
not you know okay so you're saying that
to us right here like I love this job
I'll never get to the point where I'm
like mother
[Music]
[Applause]
I hadn't thought about that if people
are making a train it would be easier
because I like cash more than it is
acceptable in the context of what you're
doing if you did do that people might go
what the hell but in your world thought
go do it back good yeah yeah it's dough
but yeah I mean I think it's just
honestly more than anything and it's a
cliche to sell but just working hard and
and understanding that complacency is
the enemy and and doing something new
every day to try to achieve your goal
and to try to be as as as well read on
the subject of what you're trying to do
is possible a lot of people times people
don't read and there are so many books
out there on on every industry and
there's so much opportunity to become
educated on a topic I just think that
the celebration of ignorance is
sometimes it gets in people's way holy
[ __ ] I'm just gonna pass out a
compliment real quick and this is gonna
sound parental and I am older than you
so it works the you are incredibly well
healed you are credit to your parents
that's something that I remember in my
childhood thank you like I'd hear that
me like what does that mean but as a
adult with a parent [ __ ] whenever I meet
somebody now and they're like 15 to like
25 year-old range and you're pretty damn
close like that's the thing that I'm
always like taking it back by where I'm
like [ __ ] man like somebody raised you
right [ __ ] what a mom and dad do my dad
is a labor relations officer for the
county in Hamilton County in Cincinnati
and my mom works at the Children's
Hospital they're in their noble work man
did you say they're your best friends
always have been I talked to him almost
every day I'm gonna [ __ ] cry they
have clearly they've gone to shows
throughout your [ __ ] life always yeah
almost possibly to a fault my dad is
always there very prescient loud yep
really yeah like I can't get the
Rockstar life on because my dad has a
tattoo of me that's that's being a great
parent absolutely some people carry
around a picture of you like [ __ ] it put
it right there yeah
that's what I mean though like I I just
I have a really good connection with
them both and they mean a lot to me and
my wife has the same situation with her
parents so it's it's been I've been
really lucky in that one where did you
meet your lady and how long you guys
been married we've been together for
just about almost seven years and we've
been married for coming up on two in
about 16 days but we met we met on tour
and she was playing on a I was on a
festival tour and she was playing on an
acoustic stage and I happened to see her
and I told our security that I wanted to
just go stand there and be creepy every
day until she noticed me that was the
plan and then she came and watched us
play the next day so I didn't have to do
that but the plan was just to stand like
that wait cuz I figured if I was weird
she would at the very little what the
hell is this good doing and then
security yeah every great romance is
really the most uncomfortable stalking
story ever music ah yeah yeah it also
begins to with you seeing somebody not
even known what they're like and stuff
and being like oh yes she will be mine
cuz I had heard her music and I thought
her poetry and lyrics so I was like
we're gonna be friends I know what she's
all about you connected with their
material and yeah yeah now you write
your own material yeah and have been
send yes begin I collaborate with the
band and other people that I've worked
with is that [ __ ] work for somebody
that doesn't do music like I already
just have this conversation with Alanis
Morissette back in the day because she
was like the first musician like that I
knew that I could ask stupid questions
too and I was like how do you write a
song she's like oh you know you just
come up with it and you're right I said
yeah but what do you write the lyrics
first and then you figure out what it's
gonna sound like or you ride the music
first then you come up with lyrics later
on she goes it's kind of all at the same
time it's hard to explain but it's just
happening simultaneously how does it
work yeah I mean some I had had songs
where it started with a lyric or an idea
but by-and-large because of the hard
rock like things it's a lot of guitar
parts and it's very hard to dictate what
a lead part is going to be in a song
unless you're doing it kind of in
conjunction with each other so most of
our songs are written where there is a
guitar part and then I build a melody or
we build the structure of the song that
way
and then the lyric is written over top
of everything else but at least usually
I start with a title before anything
else really a beginning have you gone
like [ __ ] I'm gonna call it this yeah
it elects me conceptually like there's
this is what the song is gonna be about
like we wrote our third record that we
did was our first major label record we
did like a full movie adaptation and
treatment for it so that's a concept
record so this whole story there were
characters we had character design of
everything like we did a within and that
way all the songs had to fit beats to
get the story moving in the context of
the record so like what that titles were
really important that being said like
you could probably write a comic book
I hope so you know I've been fortunate
to work with you mentioned Gerard Way
and I've become friendly with him and I
worked with him on the line he's running
the whole [ __ ] label of business and
I've spoken to him just about my
interest in that before and he was
really encouraging so that's something
I'd love to do I mean yes if you can
write in one medium you can write in the
other particularly if you responded to
the poetry the soul the woman you
eventually married just by watching the
acoustic set yes that sounds more like
you were like she was just really cute
yeah and it grew from there Wow [ __ ]
alright so you were married when he
became a rock star the band yeah the
band took off as we were in a serious
relationship I got married kind of right
before the solo record came out but yeah
yeah we've I've been since the success
of the band I have been with with my
same partner are you a superstitious
person because now you got to stay
forever man she's yeah yeah well she's
like hooked up to a bunch of tubes a guy
stuck all of her power that's how you
know I get to do all this she's written
every lyric I just take it away from her
and then I steal them to claim all of
the [ __ ] she says you just write down
you'll keep talking when is the next
album come out or drop as they say so we
we just put out a record literally a
couple weeks ago it's called veil it
yeah and it's it's available everywhere
you can buy music it's a Black Veil
Brides record and then I'm finishing up
my new solo record right now which will
come out at the beginning of next year
and the next thing is I'm putting out a
book in the next couple of months what's
the book so I worked on it with a friend
of mine named Ryan Downey who was
sitting over there hi Ryan yeah so he
he's been interviewing me for years for
through different mediums and so we the
idea was I wanted to write about kind of
what I'm talking to you about tonight my
story and the story of someone who is
it's not a memoir because I'm too young
for that but the idea of like how this
happened and how you could possibly do
it too you know
and so he had been interviewing me for
years and so we had all this collection
of interviews from the time I was 16 and
worse at speaking that I am now and so
now and kind of you earned a credit to
your parents yeah and taking and I also
I've been sober for about a year and a
half I was a very heavy drinker for
quite a while oh and so ignore all this
yeah being able to talk about kind of my
journey through that and and taking all
these interviews of like some of which I
was very drunk for and rereading and
taking little pieces and bits out of it
and kind of building the story for the
last couple years through stuff that
I've written and said stuff that I have
told him interviews that we've done kind
of the whole thing beautiful ma'am when
will it be done when is it out well it
was supposed to be out this week but it
is not so uh you know we had we had we
had to change some things so but it's
gonna be coming out soon okay night man
what's beautiful about somebody that
makes their success is if they even have
a remote thought about reaching back to
like tell others hey this is how you
[ __ ] do it man
you're arts in the right [ __ ] place
so you know in this business some people
get successful and we sit around going
like they don't deserve it they're
[ __ ] shitheels or whatever that has
nothing to do with it it has something
to do with if you have something to sell
that being said holy [ __ ] it's nice that
something nice happened to a nice
[ __ ] kid thank you again give it up
for Andy ladies
excellent y'all say
[Applause]
fantastic so [ __ ] thin all right man
I know oh my god
I mean he literally stuck the microphone
in your pants and those pants were tight
and there was still room for a
microphone rock and roll oK we've come
to that part of the show ladies and
gentlemen where we turn to you the
audience to provide the rest of the
contest context context [ __ ] as always
we're gonna do Q&A now we got ten
tickets five sets of two as always from
our good friend Brett Deacon and the
folks at the 40x theater where you could
go see a movie if you've never seen a
movie in 4dx oh my god it's it's
fantastic it smells like it smells like
in the movie there's the the seats move
around and shows like a thrill ride but
you're watching a movie at the same time
good times
we thank the folks at 40x they're always
giving us these movie vouchers we give
them out to you if you ask a question
and that question is quote-unquote
worthy it's got to be something that
both me and Mark can answer and stuff
can't be like one side and stuff it
should be something don't ask like hey
man you had a heart attack what's that
like I've already talked about that but
I will talk about it more if anyone's
really interested Bob but let's keep it
to something we can both discuss and
stuff so that being said we turn to JC
for prior to this [ __ ] fine
establishment scum and villainy Cantina
and we say who's our first victim sir
and we meet Hey yes hey what's your name
give it up for miles everybody
what's on your mind sir well I just want
to say hi hi Milwaukee Wisconsin with my
lady is about hey are you both from
Milwaukee
what's your bargain but kinda okay marry
Milwaukee home of the bronze Fonz statue
right for sure for sure well you could
see a [ __ ] bronze version of Fonzie
just stand-in there take pictures with
him shoot
I just wanted quick give a shout-out to
Alex Scott and Brandon Evans back at
home the fortress of solid dude podcast
buddies that's what is the name of your
podcast the fortress of solid dudes that
is a [ __ ] that's a genius title well
done friend Jordan was like that's the
dumbest [ __ ] ever no that's good it's
good [ __ ] you Jordan it's a podcast
about geek stuff but it could also be a
fantastic gay porn title as well okay
the kind of fortress of solitude is
title all right what do you want to know
mom well my main question is infinity
Wars is coming up and man I gotta say I
Kevin I love your stuff I love mark
barnard and you guys are [ __ ] funny
you basically are like the new Jay and
Silent Bob for me I love you guys don't
tell Jason Mewes that Rick is [ __ ]
hard I mean I love Jay as well I guess
my question for mark and Kevin would be
I guess infinity wars the next two are
gonna the next two Avengers movies are
gonna kind of wrap up the Avengers I
feel like you guys talking about how
Chris Evans is out
I feel like Downey's is gonna go out or
at least they're gonna send them off how
I think one of my favorite parts of the
podcast is when you guys just kind of
riff and just like oh what the movie
[ __ ] win this direction
how would you both individually want to
see Downey and Evans go down in the
Avengers on each other or at least
that's how you end the universe stand in
your Fortress of Solitude
we [ __ ] beat Spanos what should we do
shwarma [ __ ] that come here oh god damn
it what would I do what a great question
what would I do
I feel Tony and nut should die but oh my
god that would be crazy satisfying if
they do kill him off and I've always
said I hope he becomes the AI inside the
next suit so thinks he becomes Jarvis oh
my god how could they not it'll be the
easiest job in the world for him to do
he'll show up at a [ __ ] ADR joint and
loop for about an hour just get to be
himself as long as the lines help the
[ __ ] plot forward and still be a part
of that world and it would be very Tony
Stark
- like I downloaded my intelligence or
blah blah blah and created like a Jarvis
himself as a [ __ ] Jarvis Tony instead
so I I hope they I'm not hope they kill
him
I might be okay whether they kill him as
long as he remains the voice of the suit
if they kill him and he's not the voice
of the suit then they've got some
splainin to do because are those movies
Robert Downey jr. is like the crucial
ingredient you know I can't have [ __ ]
soup without water he's water and that
doesn't sound like a compliment but he's
like the basis of all living things him
he's magic in those movies so I would
hate to see him go away entirely so I'd
like to see that why don't like to but
if I had to do it myself
Thanos beat [ __ ] out of Tony Stark you
know to death absolutely and the III he
becomes the AI in the suit for whoever
picks it up next you I think that fan
OHS would almost beat Tony to death
except that Steve Rogers steps in does
saves his life sacrifices his life
because it goes back to that line about
like I lay down on the wire so another
guy can crawl over that's what Steve
Rogers is and they do nice callbacks in
those movies they always remember that
[ __ ] oh god that name gonna make me want
to cry that's powerful that I hadn't
thought about that a navy cap is saving
[ __ ] iron man's life and
think that that Marvel is introducing
there needs to be a captain leading the
Avengers and Marvel is giving us a
captain in Captain Marvel I see I see no
reason why you can't cross those
timelines and absolutely Captain Marvel
could lead the Avengers yes in the
comics you could do it here yeah let's
not be mistaken I don't think Avengers
movies are gonna stop they're gonna keep
making them I just think this iteration
of the Avengers looks destined for doom
but they've earned it it's not cheap
[ __ ] gimmick we've had these
characters a lot of them for 10 [ __ ]
years at this point
in some cases so we built up
relationships with them we're tied into
them emotionally so we couldn't make
that movie so satisfying you know in a
world where some of those characters are
going to drop as always one of the
biggest complaints about these movies
there's no [ __ ] stakes everybody
lives forever it sounds like it's not
gonna happen
not so much yeah alright great question
you get could I tell you what the [ __ ] I
think should [ __ ] happen but I don't
think they're gonna [ __ ] do No give
it up we told you ours you tell you go
go okay they're not gonna do this
[ __ ] Doctor Strange is the time gem
yes I saw a [ __ ] YouTube video we're
[ __ ] Tom Hall and him we're in a
[ __ ] interview together and they were
like we can't tell you about it we're in
the movie a lot together and it's really
funny my theory spider-man's gonna get
his ass kicked and then [ __ ] Pepper
Potts is gonna be like let's save the
day in an Iron Man 3 suit shield I talk
to strange is like let's [ __ ]
time-travel man they [ __ ] leave the
movie gone post credit scene they [ __ ]
up time and they come back and look what
the [ __ ] up with the Avengers tower
and there's a big four on it boom oh my
god man
drop the mic you can't drop the mic I
want to see that movie give it up for a
man convention two miles miles miles go
see a movie you earned it well done
don't leave me hanging well done [ __ ]
Fantastic Four so Avengers Tower becomes
a Baxter building [ __ ] that's good all
right man second question you got to
follow that what's your name my name is
Charlie try that
give it up for Charlie ladies and
gentlemen
first before I ask my question I just
have to say thank you you inspired me to
become a filmmaker to come here to Los
Angeles and to meet my fiancee who's
over there oh [ __ ] what do you guys get
married we're probably getting getting
married when we can afford it
oh yeah mark yeah about crime yes it's
gonna be a costume party so it's gonna
be pretty dope [ __ ] I am yeah and Mark
I did bring you I work in a theater and
I was able to grab some of the big vinyl
Black Panther posters so it's right
behind you with a little note from me
and my fiancee thank you oh it's one of
the big ones yeah it's a full six-foot
poster made out of vinyl it's two-sided
don't look at the backside it's a
wrinkle in time so that's cool that
works right on the ceiling everything's
better that's beautiful man I just
wanted to know I was a journalist for a
while and I just wanted to know for I
was in the Marines I was a
photojournalist and you were in the
Marines as well thanks very service okay
give it up for a life and I just want to
know because a journalism sort of
influenced my sort of creativity
how has journalism for markup helped out
with your creativity we writing comics
and you've been working on scripts and
stuff like that working your way into
that world and Kevin you're kind of a
journalist now with all the interview I
mean hundreds of hundreds of interviews
job and how does that sort of affected
you you would go first I think for me
journalism helped more from from a work
ethic perspective I think the fact that
I've always worked for either a weekly
magazine or a daily newspaper or an
hourly website the fact the idea of
being Precious about anything is gone
because it's got to get done magazines
got to go out there can't be blank pages
in this newspaper you know it's it's
good enough when it's done and it's
to be done so I can do more and the idea
being able to work with people you know
when learning how to interface with
other people learning how to communicate
and collaborate journalism is very much
about that it's not the you know the the
lone journalist on the frontlines
anymore it's there's a bunch of people
in a newsroom and we're all working
together towards a common goal which is
a newspaper or a story or whatever that
is but it's also you know and it's also
speaks to some of what he does is it
gives you an ear for dialogue you know
being able to talk to people from all
walks of life from every possible place
you could be from learning to listen to
how people talk from different places
and learning what like dialogue on a
page is different from dialogue as we
speak like we have a tendency to want to
make it perfect but people don't talk
perfect you know they man goal sentences
they abuse ground Piazza the Andy [ __ ]
spoke perfect man I mean these credit to
his [ __ ] parody but but the idea that
that conversation isn't perfect and
nobody ever says what they mean is
valuable when you're writing dialogue
and trying to get to convey information
in a way that feels real but yeah it's
those things it's it's learning how to
work with people and learning how to
listen to people
Josh Roush who shoots a babylon show all
the time when he's been working on a
documentary about the late great Michael
parks so there's a recording of parks an
interview I did with them at our theater
SModcast years ago when it existed and
it's in the documentary so Josh wanted
to shoot at SModcast because there's no
visuals for it we didn't shoot Michael
there were no cameras or anything like
that so he wanted rather than just you
know putting up the sound like context
the room blah blah blah artsy [ __ ] so he
rented out the space that used to be
smart castle for a couple hours set up
cameras and we shot in there so I got to
go back to what was smart castle and I
was kind of like it was an emotional
moment because I realized oh [ __ ] quite
like quick stop I owe so much of my
current career to this building quick
stop built who I was for like the first
10 years instead
of smaug castle built who I've been for
the last nearly 10 years at this point
live podcasting sitting down talking to
people so I mentioned this to my wife
today I came home and sat down and she
made the mistake of being like how you
doing and it started like an hour
conversation and [ __ ] where I was like
you know being in that space reminded me
of like you know me starting this
journey where I wanted to talk a lot
like I thought I'd become a better
public speaker if I was doing all these
podcasts but I could sit down and meet
people and find out how they got to
where they got to and sometimes you're
sitting down with very like-minded
individuals and sometimes not at all but
you get to speak to people that took a
journey and and I took a journey as well
so I'm always trying to get to the
bottom of that and I like to meet others
and like how'd you do it and where'd
that come from and stuff because you
know regardless of what I did in my
career and whatnot I will always remain
first and foremost a fan like when
people do [ __ ] I'm like how'd you do
that
that's [ __ ] amazing man how do you
rise to the top of your feel there how'd
you even get noticed in a world of
[ __ ] choices so what journalism has
done for me and certainly not the
written kind of journalism I've written
a few articles but I would never
consider myself like a journalist in
print but talking to people interview
them it helps you become a better
storyteller because you you're trying to
keep a story on the rails at all times
because you jump in you're making jokes
they're going off on tangents and the
whole time I'm always listening and in
the back listening for the thread like I
got to bring us I start this
conversation and I eventually got to
bring us to somewhere where it's
satisfying it makes sense and there's an
arc and it's like oh [ __ ] I've heard of
a small version bless you of this
person's journey so it's taught me to
listen better and to find the plot
points so the story can like kind of be
cohesive for everybody else who's
listening so if you listened to me on
the podcast sometimes I'll be
interviewing people and I will explain
like they'll say something that they
take for granted other people will know
and I'm like well my audience doesn't
necessarily know this so I'll jump in
and editorialize and then [ __ ] jump
back out and stuff so it's made me a
better storyteller oddly
that's a great question man give it up
for him he gets tickets
excellent shirt excellent hat
all right JC where we're going next is
this one I did sign it that's my
signature oh no problem
thanks Joe how are you good how are you
good what's your name I'm Jesse Errol
give it up for Jesse everybody what can
we do you for well I wanted to ask you
so with infinity war coming out it's
obviously the big culmination of the big
cinematic universe I want to ask you
guys just for fun if I was kind of
disappointed with the dark universe that
we didn't get to have a cinematic
universe that was about something other
than superheroes as much as I love
superheroes so if you could make a
cinematic universe what would it be if
it wasn't super superheroes and what
would be the culmination of that
cinematic universe I have always thought
that there was more life in the League
of Extraordinary Gentlemen than we've
ever gotten I think that idea is so
crystalline and beautiful and lovely and
heartbreaking that we only ever got a
bad movie version of it kind of destroys
me inside a little bit but I would love
to be able to reunite all of those sort
of Victorian heroes and between villains
and and put it to work for real you know
build build that out and then you know
have them I don't know interact with
Shakespearean characters because why not
that's all public domain absolutely like
no reason why titania couldn't show up
in Victorian England I know there's a
lot of years apart but I don't care
ferries them to unmagic it's all magic
anyway but yeah like that that if
anybody gave me the rights to that I
think we could have a good time last
week I think there was a variation of
this where I was
like hot wheels which was so stupid I
thought about it over the course of the
last week I was like why'd I [ __ ] say
that like what would I really what do I
think could be a [ __ ] universe like a
movie like a series of movies that
sustain a storyline with characters that
have history with the audience now you
create something like Pacific Rim you're
starting something from scratch that's
new IP and suddenly you don't know if
it's going to connect fingers cross and
stuff now they've released the sequel
it opened number one and stuff mark says
he dug it so they're on their way to
building universe but what everyone
wants is like a man''ôs rush of
characters from your childhood you know
because they're counting on your kids
money but they count on your money more
so like that's how they get us with
these Marvel movies it's like oh my god
this is the Fountain of Youth and [ __ ]
so you need something that you can't
just start from scratch need something
that has a nostalgia built into it
something that everybody every child at
one point was familiar with breakfast
cereal pitchman the Trix rabbit Coco
sunny the Coco Puffs bird the rice
krispies kids the bee Frank and Mary the
monster cereals like there are a lot of
us these characters raised us and built
our bodies and [ __ ] like that so I think
you could totally make a [ __ ]
crossover fuck-off universe with all
those characters and on top of it it's
just one fat commercial for unhealthy
American food I would if somebody was
like you can do anything you want I'd be
like I want to do all the [ __ ] and
that includes crossing universes like
Kellogg's is gonna meet the post
characters and [ __ ] like that for the
first time so that's what I would do
breakfast shirts get like you get like
an addiction metaphor with like the
church rabbit and Cookie Crisp guy and
like everyone [ __ ] everything they'll do
jobs that's at the heart of the [ __ ]
mystery what happened to Lucky's pot of
gold and [ __ ] like that I also still
think that you know call back to an old
episode of SModcast but World War Seuss
yes is still pretty strong that's true
World War Seuss every ceased character
crossing
/ and [ __ ] like that that's a great
question did you give your answer I did
I gave mine he wins tickets give it up
for Malaysia I got dizzy with the bad
guy beat chester Cheetah cheeto Chester
cheeto would be the bad guy in that
universe yeah my crossing them over with
cereal like the chip guy we're losing my
shit's pure keep your [ __ ] cheeto at
it
let me Captain Crunch is your hero right
I mean yeah you got enough characters in
the serial universe you don't even have
to bother with the snack people and [ __ ]
like that
that's in the sequel that's when you
bring in the Keebler elves
how are you sir what's your name hi my
name is EJ you weren't a bogus on chef
2,000 thousand five you were there and
Ajay was there the whole day fine so
I've dug this out of my beautiful to see
I love that shirt for those that don't
follow this sort of thing we used to
hold film festivals all the time I don't
know why we haven't done it in recent
years I guess maybe because the movies
I'm making are so [ __ ] stupid but uh
we used to hold these film festivals we
did them in these on the East Coast in
Red Bank all the time called vulgar
thumb where we'd show like you know all
the movies we ever made so when I came
out here in 2002 we opened up a Jay and
Silent Bob's secret stash in West but at
one point and me and Bob Chapman treaty
designs held up a vulgar thon out here
and you know we were like we're to do it
because you can write to any [ __ ]
theater so I said let's rent the
Cinerama Dome so we rented the Cinerama
Dome and held it for all day long and
showed like a series of [ __ ] flicks
at camera which was but I remember we
showed a long ass cut of Jersey girl and
the first people like now but then they
liked it like after after we were done
it was wonders to cure nays with Affleck
was there and that's right Affleck
showed up and Jason Lee and Joey was
there and stuff we did the twine I think
like an anniversary of chasing amy was
around that time so we shot Mallrats who
did a ten-year anniversary I have that
only went to that is why [ __ ] man that
was a great [ __ ] event but they
changed the rules of the of the Cinerama
Dome from there forward because when we
got it we rented it like I was like how
much is it to rent the Cinerama Dome for
the day and I it was eight thousand
bucks so they're like eight thousand I
was like I have it for the whole day for
eight thousand I'd do anything I want
they're like well don't [ __ ] in it but
yes like yeah it's yours
so I said fantastic and you know I think
they were [ __ ] stoked for the eight
thousand bucks like can you believe
somebody rented this [ __ ] joint [ __ ]
but I sold tickets like on my website
[ __ ] the tickets like more than paid for
the for the rental of the joint yeah and
so when the tickets like sold out and
the tickets were like 80 bucks a pop or
whatever in that place seats a couple
hundred [ __ ] people like the event
was making money and so we got a call
from the person who was running it at
that point gone oh whoa
we didn't know you were gonna sell
tickets to an event in met Dolan I said
what you think I was writing it for the
[ __ ] worse I'm gonna have an event and
stuff like that and like oh well we just
feel like you know maybe we should
receive part of that gate and I was like
oh but we don't that's not in the
agreement at all like I rented this
place or wall in it for a grant I get to
keep all the money and stuff and they
were pissed about it and they change
their policy after that so if you're
ever rent that place then they get a
piece of the gate as well it was just
smart for them and stuff and I didn't
beat them at their game it's just that
wasn't a requirement because how many
people ever walked in and said I'll rent
the [ __ ] joy but I knew we had a way
to fill the joints as well so whenever I
look at that shirt or whenever I go to
the ArcLight and or the Cinerama Dome I
always feel like when I walk in there
like there is the piece of [ __ ] changed
everything for everybody any of that
what's your question well before I get
to it may I plug my podcast oh my god
okay absolutely pockets it's called
scratch the surface it's on iTunes and
iHeartRadio and it's most in depth
thanks it's mostly an in-depth interview
podcast with a comic book writers
actors directors writers or SAS Stephen
tonight the director of the Grimm he's
coming up future gasps Vincent
d'Onofrio's for upcoming guests to get
the kingpin himself
yes sir yes sir but my question is so
homecoming kind of set up I think a
sinister six possible movie yes I'm
doing the introduction of the vulture
and the scorpions well yeah and Drew
Goddard was pulled from daredevil season
want to write a sinister six movie which
looked like it was going to get scrapped
because the Spider Man was you know that
because it was part of the Andrew
Garfield's yeah man yeah but then maybe
they'll still use part of that script
since they paid for it but who would you
guys like to see as your sinister six
it's Mike Mysterio all six characters
[Music]
honestly I of course vulture a great
addition they teased us with scorpion so
I'd take him as well I'm no kid I think
Mysterio is a villain that lends himself
to movies like he's master [ __ ] you
know mystery the illusion and movie
magic and his character Quentin Beck
came from [ __ ] movies and stuff so
definitely Mysterio right now yeah I
actually I know a lot of people [ __ ] on
that movie but I like their version of
Rhino with Paul Giamatti in a like what
essentially like a transformer suit yes
I like the version of him as a giant
bruiser who is molecularly bonded to a
suit yeah that's what it was when I was
a kid yeah like the tragedy of a dude
who has to spend his entire life in a
rhino suit like imagine waking out look
all right triangle get a job no wonder
he's so pissed except for the stupid
suit with the horn and everything I'd
like to be married again but I got this
stupid suit with the horn like just
every day is another series of assaults
on his sense of humanity because he's
bonded into a dumb gray suit and he has
to live with people constantly being
like do I make you horny
he's like I [ __ ] hate that joke all
right so we got we got vulture we got
scorpion we got Mysterio
we got rhino electro venom I mean yeah
but they tried that once and their
interpretation wasn't great but the you
know if they put him in the [ __ ] big
star mask absolutely
but listen we'll table that for a moment
and keep going he's got a deep bench
Kraven Oh Kraven the hunter yes
absolutely because then it sets you up
for doing fearful symmetry one day which
is such a great story I was thinking do
we need a goblin we've seen so many
[ __ ] green goblins and hobgoblins and
all these spider-man movies so maybe we
table Green Goblin and Hobgoblin for the
monarch tupis Doctor Octopus [ __ ]
Doctor Octopus there's the character
that lends himself to cinematic and
present interpretation and they did a
great job with that character before why
not [ __ ] keep it going all right so
that's five we hit six you can go up to
ten that was six yeah
Mysterio vulture vulture scorpion Rhino
rhino
Kraven dakka dakka yeah that's pretty
[ __ ] cool I feel like in the movie
they're setting up Shocker is being one
of them I mean all right I take it that
character wasn't bad but you know [ __ ]
they got a as I said a deep bench a deep
toy box of like Spidey rogues his rogues
gallery probably as good as Batman's
rogues gallery so they can kind of do
[ __ ] like crazy quilt the man with the
x-ray eyes
or what is the was the guy the team of
dudes and spider-man ones tall ones got
a cowboy hat and [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] I forget their name thus some
things they can't they haven't even
touched that there's so many characters
they've never gone [ __ ] near so I
don't know those are my six yeah
whose elaborated great question you went
to [ __ ] tanks get up or I'm late
gentlemen all right I want to slide it
yes again it's called what scratch the
surface go check it out okay man final
question of the evening what's your name
sir mr. cool my name's Cory lots of
pressure
hi there's a lot of pressure give it up
Cory everybody where you gonna take us
home what do you got for us Cory
so Kevin you've been absolutely a huge
part of the CW and us getting on board
with it and staying on board with the CW
mark your writing skills are
incomparable we give you guys the torch
and say okay
CW says six episodes of any character
mark who do you write and do you let
Kevin direct it
not if you want it to succeed my friend
six episodes of any character in the DC
Universe I'm assuming right cuz it's got
to be on CW I do challenges of the
unknown yeah they're living on borrowed
time yeah I think I think some big giant
cosmic space traveling Pope heroes you
know done right done today like Indiana
Jones meets Fantastic Four why would you
not watch six episodes of that and he
can direct all of them look at that oh
thank you yeah that's a good poll let me
think I always say the question so I'll
put that on the shelf for the moment but
I believe the question would be the one
I'd go for but no well we're like you
can't do it let me think what else in DC
Oh [ __ ] you know some of my favorite
comics of my youth was jl i you know
Justice League International and jail a
Justice League America but it was just
called Justice League with what's his
name the funny version hello IRA and
Giffen if that was the name
[ __ ] the Giffen des mattis and what was
the Warner and Maguire such a magical
run of the book and they even made dark
Batman work in a comedic sense like they
played they played up his whole like now
he's the
ARC night and [ __ ] like that I thought
they did a fantastic job so I would say
you could take of that world of course
two of the most beloved characters were
Blue Beetle and Booster Gold and you
could do an excellent [ __ ] ongoing
series with those characters one guy
who's like you know Batman but not Bruce
Wayne and stuff Ted Kord has his own
[ __ ] industry and created the [ __ ]
Blue Beetle suit and stuff I wouldn't do
the modern one with a scarab beetle that
turns him into a beetle I like it but I
kind of like the idea of like I'm a tech
billionaire and I just decided to start
fighting crime and stuff that's that's
tried-and-true origin story in the
comics Batman
Green Arrow the same thing I'm a
billionaire and I just want to do what's
right
so that character is wonderful and then
you get Booster Gold who comes back from
the [ __ ] future with information
that's what makes him a superhero and
stuff and he's got to try to learn how
to be a decent human being you give
totally [ __ ] great series out of that
man put Nathan Fillion in the role of
Booster Gold that [ __ ] right amount
of Canadian swagger does that mean -
dick gets the the Blue Beetle role that
would be fantastic you and me we're
gonna rule the CW that's a little bit of
- Nick as well man cuz [ __ ] it - dick
better than one dick and he's very very
[ __ ] funny that is those two dudes
man they are [ __ ] Blue Beetle and
Booster Gold to some degree they're
waiting for some Kevin Smith dialog
house they're doing quite well without
Kevin Smith they're like we got Joss
Whedon [ __ ] great question give
it up for him ladies of Jones thank you
Cory
[Applause]
pleasure man pleasure
oh [ __ ] these are for me looking great
oh [ __ ] I get to take this stuff home
thank you I like coming here cuz I get
free [ __ ] I got Black Panther though I
know you got the biggest free thing [ __ ]
its life size and [ __ ] that posters
taller than you I know I mean even steps
to not impugning your height I think you
were made perfectly
it's what every mother wants to hear
ladies and gentlemen have you had a good
time this evening I can't thank you
enough for coming out man give it up for
our good friends here at the scum and
villainy Cantina for giving us a [ __ ]
home and give it up for the man's in my
love without whom there ain't no fat man
I'm Batman mr. mark Bernard and that is
fat man I'm Batman this week I'm Kevin
Smith I'm mark Barnard a tune in next
week same fat time same fat channel
SModcast calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith give it up for marks mom
you